ON BEHALF OF THE STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
WE WELCOME YOU TO OUR FOR OUR
FIRST BILL HEARING OF THE SEASON.
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU
ARE HERE TODAY WE HAVE FOUR
MEASURES ON OUR DOCKET.
ALONG WITH OUR COMMITTEE RULES
AND THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT MISS
LANCHESTER WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY --
AS WE DO HAVE NOT YET BEEN ABLE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM THERE
SEVERAL COMMITTEES THAT ARE
MOVING I EVEN AS WE SPEAK.
AS SOON AS WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
WILL THEN MOVE ON THE COMMITTEE
RULES AS WELL AS THE APPOINTMENT
OF THE COMMITTEE ASSISTANT.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO START
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE WORK ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO THAT'S S. B..
THIRTY FOUR BEFORE CENTER WINNER
GETS INTO WHAT I DO WANT TO SAY
I'M GONNA TO VOTE IN EDUCATION --
IF I WALK OUT SOONER WINNER IS
NOT AT ALL ANY DISRESPECT BUT
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO OUR VERY CAPABLE VICE
CHAIR AND I WANT.
TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS TO MISTER
MORLOCK.
BECOMING VICE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE IN LOOKING FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU SIR IS WELL SO AND SO
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE SERVICE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE.
CENTER WE ARE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ON SB THIRTY FOUR GOOD MORNING I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO YOU IN
YOUR SUPPER OR KING WITH US IN
THIS BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AND OR WHOSE TITLE IS
THE DENNIS PERONE BROWNIE MARY
OCT.
DENNIS PRONE AND BROWNIE MARY
BEING.
TOO EARLY LEADERS AND THE
MEDICAL CANNABIS MOVEMENTS WHO
WERE PROVIDING --
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
TO PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV I IN
SAN FRANCISCO BEFORE THERE WAS
ANY EFFECTIVE TREATMENT --
FOR HIV AIDS --
THE SAVE LIVES AND MAKE PEOPLE'S
LIVES BETTER AND SO WE HONOR
THEM BY TITLING THIS BILL IN
THERE.
IN THERE HONOR AND MEMORY --
COLLEAGUES I SP THIRTY FOUR WILL
INSURE THAT LOW INCOME --
PATIENTS WHO RELY ON MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO SURVIVE AND BE
HEALTHY.
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
I'VE DONATED MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO PURCHASE MEDICAL
CANNABIS --
AND THEY HAVE BEEN RECEIVING IT
FOR FOR PASSIONATE CARE OUR
COLLECTIVES AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE THE
KIND OF THIS FOR FREE.
HI THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IN MY COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH HAS BEEN SO
IMPACTED.
BY HIV AIDS IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
OTHER COMMUNITIES SUFFERING FROM
CANCER GLAUCOMA ANOTHER HEALTH
CHALLENGES MANY VETERANS RELY ON
THESE PROGRAMS --
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
UNFORTUNATELY --
WHEN -- WHEN --
CANNABIS --
FOR USE WAS LEGALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA I'LL BE A PROP.
SIXTY FOUR THE BEES --
PROGRAMS WERE SUBJECTED I
BELIEVE INADVERTENTLY --
TO TAXATION I SO NOW IF YOU ARE
GIVING AWAY A FREE MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO LOW INCOME PATIENTS.
YOU'RE STILL REQUIRED TO PAY ALL
OF THE CULTIVATION AND USE TAXES.
AND THAT IS CAUSING THESE
COLLECTIVES PROGRAMS TO SHUT
DOWN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO REVENUE --
SURVEY WE NEED TO BE EXPANDING
ACCESS -- TO
MEDICINE INTO HEALTHCARE.
NOT A CONTRACTING IT WE WOULD
NEVER TAX PRESCRIPTION DRUGS --
FOR EXAMPLE --
SO THE BILLWILL --
EXAMS ARE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS.
FROM ALL TAXES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
WITH ME --
TODAY IS --
GALLAGHER WHO IS A FORMER
PATIENT OF SWEETNESS SWEETLY
COLLECTIVE A COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAM IN MY DISTRICT IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WHO HAS SEEN THE BENEFITS OF
ACCESS?
TO A FREE MEDICAL CANNABIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY I JUST WANT.
TO SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR LAST
YEAR NOTE. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT ON FILE THE DISPENSER IN
VERY GRATEFUL FOR WORKING WITH
US AND I JUST WANNA TAKE MOM SAY
THANK YOU TO SEND A WINNER THIS
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. FOR
THOUSANDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA --
IN GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THE BILL --
SO WOULD LIKE TO BE A TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESS SIR GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME.
HI MY NAME'S DOUG GALLAGHER.
IN A LOW INCOME VETERANS SOONER.
I HAVE GOT AIDS AND CANCER.
NOT TOTALLY BLIND A MOSTLY DOWN.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS HAVE
BEEN RECEIVING COMPASSIONATE
CARE OUT OF US.
OFFER FREE.
AND IF I HADN'T HAD ACCESS TO
THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW I WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH.
ALL ILLNESSES THAT I'VE HAD OVER
THE YEARS.
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WAS
PASSED.
BECAUSE THE GODS SAID NUMBER.
IN REALITY THE TAXES MAY A LOT
OF THE PATIENTS ONTO THE BLACK
MARKET WEATHER'S.
BAD CANVASES CUP SIZE ALL UP.
WE'RE HOPING THE SP.
THIRTY FOUR WHEEL REMEDIES TO
THE SITUATION --
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
A BUS TO TO HELP.
MAKE ALL OF YOUR SEARCH FOR
FOLKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR ANYONE
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A ME TOO
THAT MEANS JUST YOUR FIRST AND
LAST IN YOUR ORGANIZATION AS WE
KNOW YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
AS SOON AS WE TAKE THOSE WHO
WERE IN SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA STAB
WISH A QUORUM ONCE WE SALVAGE A
CORE WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADOPT
COMMITTEE RULES THEY WILL GO TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU --
CENTER WINNER [inaudible]
OKAY.
PLEASE SIR --
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
IN OTHER MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
MEMBERS POLIO --
SHUDDER INTO A ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY SAM CISCO IN
SUPPORT THINKING THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS NOT BECAUSE OF CANNABIS
BECAUSE IT IS A CHOICE TO
VETERANS AND SECOND IS ABLE TO
CHOOSE.
NOT TO BE ADDICTED TO OPIATES
NOT TO HAVE SUICIDAL THOUGHTS
BECAUSE OF ANTI DEPRESSANTS
WHICH IS ON THE FDA WARNING
LABELS THIS ISN'T ABOUT CANNABIS.
THIS IS ABOUT LIFE FOR THE POOR
BECAUSE THEY WERE PART OF THE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC DRAFT WHICH
LOOKS AT THE PORES FILLING THEIR
LISTED RIGHT GOOD MORNING GOING
BACK AS FOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING TAMMY MARTIN WITH
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MR TERRON MISTER
VICE CHAIR --
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF THE
NOR CAL CANNABIS AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND ALSO --
IT'S JUST GROWERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH RECEIVING THIS MORNING SIR.
MORNING LEAGUE BYNUM UNITED
MYSTIC WORKERS ASK ME LOCAL
THERE NINE THIRTY IN TRUCKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING AMOUNT EQUIP US
WITH KITANA WHAT'S IN HARTMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WELCOME BACK MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CASEY O'CONNOR ON
BEHALF OF ST TREASURE FIONA MOM
PROUD SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
A GOOD MORNING.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND CAN A CRAFT ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANKS TO CALL.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
MORNING ELIZABETH ORTIZ CHAPTER
PRESIDENT WE FOR WARRIORS
PROJECT IN SAN JOSE --
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS I AM
ALSO A VETERAN WITH --
A SURVIVOR MILITARY SEXUAL
TRAUMA WHO USES CANNABIS AS
MEDICINE --
TO MAKE ME AVAILABLE TO MY
CHILDREN AND I I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS PHONE THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MY NAME IS LAURIE.
CARE GIVER MY CANON COMMUNITY
AND I STRONGLY KNOWN BELIEVE
THAT WITH ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL
MARKETS WE WOULD HAVE ENDLESS
POSSIBILITIES FOR PATIENTS OVER
PROFITS WOULD BE THE FOCUS.
PATIENTS BECOME MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO REACH OUT BEFORE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THIS GIVES ME A
CHANCE AS A CARE GIVER TO MAKE A
DONATION OR RECOMMEND AND GIVE
INFO ON UPCOMING CANNABIS
COMMUNITY EVENT.
THAT CATER TO THEM ON HOW TALE
HOW TO MAINTAIN THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH WITH DIGNITY AND HOPE FOR
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY WERE VERY GRATEFUL GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING MORNING MY
NAME IS LINDSAY FREEDMAN AND I
AM WITH JEDI EXTRACTS.
PROJECT AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL --
WE'VE HAD TO CUT OFF OVER A
THOUSAND PATIENTS CANCER
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO THE CHANGES IN
THE LAW AND THEY'VE HAD A LOT OF
NEGATIVE REPERCUSSIONS SINCE
BEING OFF THE PROGRAM SO I'M
REALLY URGING THE SUPPORT TO GET.
BACK TO EVERYBODY THANK THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS FREE MEN.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
pI'M A CANCER SURVIVOR AND A
BENEFICIARY OF JEDI SHELTER
PROGRAM AND JUST I WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
STRONGLY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING TODAY.
GOOD MORNING.
HI ELLEN COME FROM CALIFORNIA
NORMAL WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
BECAUSE COME [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
SHOT JOHNSON WITH THESE
SOLUTIONS AND WE STRONG SUPPORT
SB THIRTY FOUR MR JOHNSON.
GOOD MORNING.
NEXT TO US ON BEHALF OF A FLOW
KANA OPERATION EVEN I CAN COVER
CAMPUS CAREERS ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS YOUR SHERIN MEMBERS
ANGIE MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF
CONTINUUM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GIVES MINETTI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS AT E. ALLY THE PAYMENT
OF THE PARENTS FROM CLARGES
NETWORKS MY SON WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH T. CELL LEUKEMIA WHEN HE
WAS TWO YEARS OLD.
I'M EXPERIENCING NEAR DEATH
SITUATIONS I WORK FOR A
CORPORATE COMPANY I LOST MY JOB --
WITH -- SEE
THE OIL WE CHANGE OUR MIND I'M
OUT OF A CONCERT OF MINES.
AND HIS LABS IMPROVED HIS HELL
LIFE BACK IN HIS CHILDHOOD SO WE
DO SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND HOPE THAT --
YOU WILL PROVIDE MEDICINE FOR
THE SICK THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING BOB --
SEAN WITH A WEED FOR WARRIORS
AND AIRFORCE VETERAN AND STRONG
SUPPORT US BE --
THIRTY FOUR MAINLY BECAUSE OF MY
ILLNESSES --
RARE MEAN DISEASE AND ABILITY TO
GET THOSE MEDS THAT I NEED --
FOR THAT DISEASE AND ALSO FROM
MY PTSD THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NEIL YARBOROUGH AMMAN
MARINE CORPS VET.
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO I WOULD HE
LEAVE MY HOUSE WAS ON THIRTY TWO
DIFFERENT MEDS VA GAVE ME.
THE WEED FOR YEARS CHANGE MY
LIFE THEY SAY MY LIFE.
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED.
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED WITH
COMPASSION AND NOW IT'S ENDING
WITH COMPASSION.
IF THESE BILLS DON'T PASS.
PEOPLE LIKE ME --
GONNA DISAPPEAR.
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU CAN USE YOUR ROVER GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE MORNING SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUIS MARTINEZ
ON THE LEADERSHIP OF STARTING
WITH FOR YEARS --
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
MAINLY BECAUSE THE VA MEN'S AND
THEN MAKE THE FUNCTIONAL ZOMBIE
I NOW FUNCTION FATHER INVOICING
HUMAN BEING GENERAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
MORNING MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MONICA CUT HILL I'M
WITH WEED FOR WARRIOR PROJECT --
I HAVE PTSD FROM GOING TO IRAQ
DURING THE INVASION.
MY SON HAS.
SEIZURES MY EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER --
WAS ATTACKED WHEN SHE WAS
SIXTEEN ALL OF US.
USE CANNABIS FOR OUR PTSD AND
FOR OUR PAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MAR INTERNET WITH THE UNITED CAN
AS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
OUR TRADE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
OVER SEVENTY DISPENSARIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE SEEN PATIENTS FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS.
WE NEED IS BUILT TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE PATIENTS AT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE DO A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT LASING GENTLEMAN. TO
PLEASE SIR WELCOME --
TOM FULTON FROM WE FORCED
PROJECTS.
TO THIS OPPORTUNITY IT JUST.
IT GIVES THE PILLS OF THEM FROM
THE VA OR FREE THIS IS GIVE US A
AT LEAST A CHANCE TO GO TO
SOMETHING ELSE AND SO I REALLY.
IN SUPPORT SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
MORNING MY NAME IS CARLOS BAEZ A
MARINE CORPS VETERAN --
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I GOT
HURT IN THREE YEARS AGO ON THE
DEPLOYMENT.
I GAINED ABOUT A HUNDRED POUNDS
HAVE LOST SEVENTY FIVE OF THEM
SO FAR AND IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF
THE WHEAT FOR WARRIORS.
AND IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF THE
MEDICINE THAT THEY GIVE IT TO US
AND IT'S NOT JUST WHAT EVERYBODY
THINKS IT IS BUT I'M TRYING TO
BREAK THE STIGMA THAT IT REALLY
DOES HELP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR STORY GOOD MORNING SIR
MORNING MARC CARRILLO WEED FOR
WATER PROJECT BRING FOR VETERANS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR GOOD MORNING.
ROBIN LOVE MAN ARMY VETERAN I'M
ALSO AN AMNESTY SURVIVOR WITHOUT
MARK AND THESE VETERANS FROM THE
WAY FOR YOUR PROJECT I WOULDN'T
BE STANDING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE.
GOOD MORNING MORNING MY NAME IS
BRYCE WISER MARINE CORPS COMBAT
VETERAN I RUN THE OAKLAND
CHAPTER FOR WE FOR WHERE PROJECT.
AND CANNABIS SAVE MY LIFE.
AND THE FORD ABILITY OF CANNABIS
ESPECIALLY ON THE RECREATIONAL
MARKET.
IS JUST TO IT IN ORDER TO AFFORD
A MONTH'S WORTH THE MEDICINE IS
THE IMPOSSIBLE.
AND SO THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED IN ORDER.
TO KEEP SAVING LIVES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING. FOUR MEMBERS PAUL
I'M SOME MEMBER OF THE FOUR
PRODUCT AS WELL I'M --
MOVED HERE FROM OHIO IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HAVING
ACCESS AND HAVE BEEN THAT THE
THE FREE STUFF THE PROJECT GIVES
US IS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MORNING.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH ARONIE ON THE
FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR OF THE
SWEET LEAF COLLECTIVE WE'VE BEEN
PROVIDING FREE CANNABIS TO LOW
INCOME TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND WE
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND I APOLOGIZE I THINK I FORGOT
MY NAME I'M PART OF THE LEAF
WHERE'S MY NAME SEAN KERN AN
ARMY THAT.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY VERY
GRATEFUL --
LEASING GERMAN NOT TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON
MOMENTARILY NOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH COMMITTEE RULES AS
WELL.
AS OUR COMMITTEE SECRETARY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WERE
EVERY SEED THE COMMITTEE RULES --
IS THERE A MOTION TO BE ABLE TO
PROVE.
THE MOBILE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WINNER --
MISS LANE --
I'M SORRY WE NEED A QUORUM
APOLOGIZE MY GOODNESS THAT WOULD
ALWAYS HELP FIRST --
MISS LANE CHESTER --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WARRIORS
[inaudible]
WIDESPREAD MORLOCK [inaudible]
HELLO YELTSIN [inaudible]
WINNER PRESENT.
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE IS IN
GERMAN WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR WINNER TO BEIRUT DOT
THE COMMITTEE RULES AS WELL AS
RE APPOINTMENTS LANCHESTER IS A
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT.
I'M MISSING CHESTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE
HEY THERE YOU GO HI.
WHY I WRITE?
WARLOCK.
OR LACK I FELL [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
YES.
YES THE WAITER HI YOU'RE ON THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON TO DO THE COMMITTEE RULES IN
ALL RIGHT SO THAT IS CURRENTLY
EIGHTY SIX ZERO WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN --
FOR MS FURTADO I'M GONNA TURN
THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
WHO WILL BE ABLE TO START TAKING
ANY OPPOSITION IF WE DO OF
OPPOSITION YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
I APOLOGIZE AND GO VOTE IN
EDUCATION AND I'LL BE BACK
MOMENTARILY THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER IN THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES.
THE DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION YOU HAVE A
CLOSING COMMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IRA. ONE TESTER IS.
HI OR MY GOD BELLE.
I HER DAUGHTER.
NELSON.
NELSON I WINNER HI.
HI.
WHY DO YOU HAVE [inaudible] FIVE
ZERO AND THEN WE'LL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN.
NOW WE HAVE THE OTHER MEMBERS
PRESENT THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU CALLER YOUR INNER.
THEN I SHOULD BE GO TO NUMBER
BILL NUMBER ONE ON OUR AGENDA
FILE NUMBER ONE SP.
FIVE CENTRE BELL ARE YOU READY.
TO THEY WILL JUST WAIT A COUPLE
MINUTES FOR THE ROOM TO CLEAR.
ARE YOU JOHN.
JUNE.
OR SEE YOU.
REALLY BEEN HOPING FOR AND ON I
DON'T KNOW.
RIGHT IS WRONG
[inaudible]
ZERO
BELL AT ON THE SP.
FIVE AS SINCE UNDER THE GLARE IS
A JOINT AUTHOR DID YOU WANT.
TO WAIT UNTIL HE RETURNS TO
PRESENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO.
MAYBE WE COULD DO I SP ONE
TWENTY EIGHT FIRST OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE CHAIR.
OKAY GREAT.
THE ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
THANK YOU
.
ARE YOUR GOOD MORNING --
TERM MEMBERS SO.
NOW WE HAVE WORKED WITH --
OUR COMMITTEE FOR YEARS TO
CREATE --
AND REFINED --
FINANCING TOOLS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROJECTS --
ONE METHOD.
THAT WE DID --
WAS SP SIX TWENTY EIGHT WHICH I
AUTHORED --
IN -- TWENTY
FOURTEEN ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT.
THAT WAS ADOPTED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND IT WAS KIND OF
ADOPTED AS THE I GUESS.
IN RESPONSE TO THE DISSOLUTION.
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE --
STRUGGLED.
WITH THE WITH THE HOW DO WE KEEP.
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ENGINE
RUNNING.
IN A WAY WHERE IT DOESN'T HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT.
ON THE GENERAL FUND OF THE STATE.
AND ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
COMPLETE SOME PROJECTS THEY'RE
NEEDED FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
SO.
IT WAS THE ONE OF THE FIRST
ATTEMPTS [inaudible]
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS.
ARE PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH THAT WAY OF FINANCES NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROP PROJECTS.
WITH THE ATTACKS IN CURRENT
FINANCING.
OF THE PROPERTY TAX ARE
ALLOCATED. TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS ARE NOT NEW
TAXES -- OR
SPECIAL SECTIONS IN THE BONDS DO
NOT RESULT.
IN INCREASED BURDEN ON THE
TAXPAYERS.
THIS IS A USEFUL TOOL.
IT'S UNDER UTILIZED HOWEVER AND
WE LOOKED IN SOME OF THE
BARRIERS. TO UTILIZING THESE
TOOLS.
IN FACT THE THE CENTER OFFICE
RESEARCH PREPARED A STUDY
EVALUATING THESE TOOLS.
I FELT THAT --
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE THERE WERE
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
OTHER BILLS --
THE THERE WERE BARRIERS --
TO THE BILLS BEING ACTUALLY
UTILIZE IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THERE HAS
BEEN SOME.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN --
EFFECTIVELY USE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCER
DISTRICTS REQUIRE 55% VOTES TO
ISSUE BONDS.
THE VOTER REQUIRE THIS VOTER
REQUIREMENT --
WHICH WAS NOT APPLIED TO
REDEVELOPMENT BONDS.
IT WAS A BARRIER IT IT'S
BURDENSOME FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
KEY PURPOSES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS ISSUING
BONDS FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS.
IT ADDS AN ELEMENT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
AND RESTRICTS THE ABILITY.
OF INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS --
TO MAKE LONG TERM COMMITMENTS.
THE SOLUTION IS TO ELIMINATE THE
VOTE REQUIREMENT. TO ISSUE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT BARNES.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE CHAIR.
ON TO ALLOW INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT --
TO MAKE THEIR INVESTMENT AND
ALSO GETTING PUBLIC INPUT BY
HAVING A BEEFED UP PUBLIC INPUT
PROCESS.
WELL NOT HAVING FIRST FUTURE
pTHE THE PROCESS.
WE WILL ACCEPT THE COMEDIANS
AMENDMENTS AND REPLACE THE
ELECTION WITH A VOTER PROTEST
PROCESS SIMILAR TO OTHER
FINANCING BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY OUR COMMITTEE HERE.
THIS BILL SP.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT STREAMLINES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING TO THE
DISTRICT TOOL MAKES IT MORE
PRACTICAL.
AND A TRACTORS THOSE TOOL FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AND I LIKE TO TURN OUT TO MY
WITNESSES MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ABOUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO KICK US OFF IN
IF YOU COULD JUST PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES THANK YOU.
OKAY THREE MINUTES I TALK FAST
AND GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KERR
BACKS AHEAD OF THAT I'M THAT
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S A LONG NAME BUT IT'S THE
ASSOCIATION OF THE PRACTITIONERS
THE CITY COUNTY AND OTHER STAFF
THAT WORK ACROSS THE STATE TO
HELP BUSINESSES THRIVE.
SINCE THE LOSS THE REDEVELOPMENT
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN WORKING
HARD TO MOVE PROJECTS FORWARD
AND ALSO TO WRITE REVITALIZE
THEIR COMMUNITIES BUT IT'S
BECOME REALLY CLEAR.
THAT WE DO NEED TO TOOL LIKE TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING IN
PARTICULAR THE E. I. F. T. TOOL
SO THAT WE CAN BRING MORE
RESOURCES TO THE TABLE TO GET
SUBSTANTIVE PROJECTS DONE.
WE'RE REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SENATORS AND LEADERSHIP IN
INTRODUCING THE TOOL TO BEGIN
WITH AND HELPING US FIND A WAY
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
COMMUNITIES --
TO TO ACTUALLY USE THE TOOL SO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THAT YOU
HELP TO SAVE THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SET ASIDE FOR THE CD
BG PROGRAM.
AND ALSO THE WORK TAKES STAND
CLEAR AS WELL SO --
WE ASK THAT YOU WORK WITH US ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE VERY
EXCITED AT THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING IT AND
FINDING WAYS TO MAKE THE E. I.
F. T. TOOL MORE PRACTICAL
PRACTICAL.
AND USEFUL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT
THIS POINT I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO ERIN LAUREL WHO IS OUR
INCOMING CHAIR BUT ALSO THE
MANAGER THE CITY MANAGER OF THE
CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO.
SO YOU CAN HEAR A MORE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND EXPERIENCE WITH THE
TOOL ON WHY THIS IS SO NECESSARY.
I WOULD SAY THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
AND THAT --
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON MAKING IT
MORE PRACTICAL AND USEFUL TOOL
IN THE SHOP THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORE MISSING MANAGER.
THANK YOU UGH MORE COMMITTEE OF
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR CONTINUED WORK ON
THIS TOPIC OF STARTING THIS BE
SIX TWENTY EIGHT AND MOVING
FORWARD SINCE THEN.
OSCAR BACKS --
MISSIONS AND MANAGER OF THE SEA
WAS SACRAMENT OVER ONE OF THREE
IDEAS IN THE STATE WE ARE
ACTUALLY THE FIRST ONE WAS SET
UP.
THERE'S MANY MORE --
COMMUNITIES LOOKING INTO THIS
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED THIS ISSUE
LIBERATION OF OF THE USE OF THIS
TOOL THE OTHER ONE IS THE
SUBJECT OF THE OF THE NEXT BILL.
BUT ON THE BOND ISSUANCE --
ISSUE --
FIRST.
IN THE AFTERMATH REDEVELOPMENT --
THE NON GOING PROCESS OF
RESHAPING OUR TAX INCREMENT
TOOLS -- FOR
THINGS LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE
STABLE DEVELOPMENT AND INFORMAL
HOUSING --
THIS THIS THE I'VE D. TOOL HAS A
LOT OF PROMISE.
BUT AGAIN THE THE EXISTING --
REQUIREMENT IS A MAJOR OBSTACLE
FOR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
SMALLER ONES THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THAT -- VOTE
REQUIREMENT LATER ON AND THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IT TAKES TO SET
UP ONE OF THESE DISTRICTS IT'S
JUST NOT.
WORTH THE RISK IN IN KNOWING
THAT THAT'S LOOMING OUT THERE SO
WE BELIEVE WITH THIS FIX TO SEE
A LOT MORE CITIES --
MOVE AHEAD WITH DISTRICT
FORMATIONS ESPECIALLY THOSE MORE
CREATIVE DISTRICTS WE'D ALL LIKE
TO SEE MORE OF THEY COULD
INCLUDE MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS
CITIES AND COUNTIES WORKING
TOGETHER.
AUDIBLE CITIES WORKING TOGETHER
TO REALLY REALIZE THE THE
PROMISE OF WHAT HE ACT THESE CAN
BECOME.
SO ON THE AMENDMENTS WE WORK TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE --
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON THE ON
THE PROPOSED PROTEST LANGUAGE.
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT
INCLUDING CURRYING PROTEST
PROVISION IN THE STATUTE WOULD
BE HUGE DETRIMENT.
TO THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS LATER
ON IT WOULD IT WOULD PUT UP
BECAUSE A LOT OF RISK ON ON THE
BONDS OF CELLS AND BOND BUYERS
WOULD BE RELUCTANT TO TAKE THAT
ON SO WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER IF YOU'RE GONNA
CONSIDER PROTEST REVISION.
OF YOURS THAT YOU YOU CONSIDER
IT ONLY FOR TAKING PLACE THE
TIME OF THE I. T. FORMATION NOT
ON A RECURRING BASIS.
THERE'S ALSO SOME TECHNICAL
FIXES IN THE BILL THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO TAKE CARE OF AND ALSO WANTED
TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS.
THE OPPOSITION LETTER ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS YOU YOU
RECEIVED A THERE'S A COUPLE IN
THIS CHARACTERIZATIONS ABOUT THE
BILL IN THERE --
WANT TO CLARIFY THE ACT THESE
ARE NOT THE NEW TAX --
THIS IS EXISTING PROPERTY TAX SO
PORTRAYING IT AS SUCH IS IS --
INACCURATE AND AND FRANKLY WITH
WITH REPRESENTATION FROM CITY
COUNCILS AND PUBLIC MEMBERS I
THINK THE BILL OR THE ORIGINAL
YET THE STATUE WAS SET UP TO
PROVIDE THAT REPRESENTATION.
SO --
WITHOUT ALL CLOSE IN AND THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH FOR CITY
MANAGER AT WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THOSE WHO ARE INSUPPORT TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD IS FOLKS
START COMING FORWARD.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN TO
CENTERED ABOUT FOR HIS WORK THE
PUBLIC INPUT PORTION OF THE
PROTEST PORTION --
WITH IN THESE DISTRICTS ARE DUE
TO THE AMENDMENT THAT WAS
ACCEPTED BY CENTER BALLOT WILL
BE THE BEGINNING OF THE
FORMATION PROCESS --
SO VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL OTHER AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'RE DANCING HERE TODAY --
ISN'T ABOUT WOULD LIKE ME TO GO
THROUGH --
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY
WILL TURN IT OVER. TO THOSE WHO
ARE SUPPORT PERSON LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MISS SURE MEMBERS JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES WERE IN
SPORT IS MEASURED REALLY
APPRECIATE.
AT THE CENTERS TIRELESS EFFORTS
TO HELP US IMPROVEOUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS RYAN GOOD MORNING.
FOR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONNA GONNA BE HALF OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION OUR LETTER OF SUPPORT
WAS ONLY DELIVERED YESTERDAY AND
FOR THAT I APOLOGIZE BUT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU MORNING.
THANK YOU MATT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION THE CITY F SANTA
MONICA IN THE CEMETERY OF CITY
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS.
AS A WITNESS SAID WE THINK THIS
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO BRING IN
MORE YEAH IF THESE ONLINE THANK
YOU ASK FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING HELLO CHRISTY FOIL
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY
AREA GOVERNMENTS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU BECAUSE YOU THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MORNING JEFF NEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WHEN THE CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY
TOWN HELL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK THE AUTHOR AUTHOR FOR
BEING SO CREATIVE?
INSANITY [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HOLY MICHELLE
MAY HAVE WITH THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT IT WAS AN
ANNOYNCE IN THE COMMITTEE HAVE
A GOOD.
ONE MORNING MARY ELLEN SHAKE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN
CALIFORNIA SO SEE ATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY SINCE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE ONE ANSWER.
IT'S A TERM MEMBERS MATTHEW HARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION I WAITED
A BEAT BEFORE I CAME UP HERE.
WE'RE NOT EXACTLY A TWEENER
WE'RE ALL WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR WE WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL WE'RE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF TAX INCREMENT FINANCING THIS
IS NOT A NEW TAX ON OUR MEMBERS.
BUT ITS INVESTMENT BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD THE TAX
BASE OF THOSE PROPERTIES LIKE
WE'RE SEEING OUT WEST SACK --
SO AT THIS POINT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE ARE MOVING TO
SUPPORT OURSELVES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD LAST CALL.
ALRIGHT WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER TURN OVER TO THOSE WHO
OPPOSE WE HAVE --
IN INDIVIDUAL MISTER WOLF WAS
CAN BE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
AND THEN.
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
MISTER WOLF FOR SURE SIR GOOD
MORNING MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU I DAVID WOLF
HERE AT THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSED SP --
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ONE REITERATE
FIRST OF ALL MEMBERS THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT A NEW TAX
THIS USES EXISTING PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE.
THEY'RE NOT SURE WHICH OPPONENTS
MADE THAT ARGUMENT BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT US --
JUST BY WAY OF CONTEXT SENATOR
BAIL DID INTRODUCE SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
HARRY JARVIS ALSO DID OPOSE
THAT BAIL --
FOR THE REASON PRIMARILY THAT A
IT FAILED TO SET A TWO THIRDS
VOTE REQUIREMENT FOR LONG TERM-DAD -- AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL IN ITS ANY
VOTER APPROVAL SO OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE
BELL WERE CONCERNED MEMBERS THAT
SP ONE TWENTY EIGHT REALLY DOES
DISREGARD OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
OF PRECEDENT.
REGARDING THE ISSUANCE OF VOTER
APPROVED AT IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND REALLY THE
STATES ALL THE WAY BACK TO
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE
PRACTICALLY ALL BONDS NOT ALL
BUT CERTAINLY THE LARGE MAJORITY
HAVE ACQUIRED A SUPER MAJORITY
THRESHOLD.
OF 55% OR HIGHER TO BE APPROVED --
AND I THINK THAT MAINTAINING
THAT SUPER MAJORITY THRESHOLDS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THIS IS DAD THAT'S GOING TO
REMAIN ON THE BOOKS --
FOUR YEARS AFTER THE I FD BOARD
WHICH IS CONSISTING OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS PRIMARILY
HAS TURNED OUT.
THEY'VE APPROVED IT THEY TURNED
OUT THIS DATA IS ON THE BOOKS
FOR AS LONG AS FORTY FIVE YEARS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE VOTER ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN ADDITION E. I. F. T. BONDS
ARE NOT THE SAME AS LOCAL
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND.
OKAY --
LOCAL GEO BONDS HAVE THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT OF A LOCAL
GENERAL FIND BACK IN THE BLIND
YEAH I F. T. BOND THAT'S NOT THE
CASE THEY DON'T HAVE THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT.
OF THE MUNICIPALITY BACKING UP
THE SPONSOR IS NOT THAT
ASSURANCE AND WE DO THINK THAT
CREATES A MUCH GREATER RISK FOR
TAX PAYERS AS WELL AS HIGHER
INTEREST COSTS --
I WILL SAY IN REGARDS TO THE
PROTEST PROCEDURE JUST IN
CLOSING --
YOU KNOW WE ARE PLEASED
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT'S AN
AMENDMENT IN THE BILL BECAUSE IT
DOES PROVIDE SOME PROCESS FOR
TAXPAYERS TO SPEAK.
INTO THE I FD BONDS IN THE
SITUATION THEY'RE IN BUT IT'S
NOT THE SAME AS AN ACTUAL VOTE.
FOR LONG TERM DEBT AND
ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE JUST DOING
IT THE PROTEST PROCEDURE IN THE
E. I. F. T. FORMATION IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT THE SAME AS AN
ACTUAL VOTE.
ON LOCAL YOU KNOW LOCAL BOND AT
THE COULD AST UP TO FORTY FIVE
YEARS SO FOR THOSE REASONS ASK
FOR NOVA.
REFORMIST WILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITH ACTING NOW FOR THE
MICROPHONE THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED
PLEASE COME.
FOR LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO OPEN UP FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MR VICE CHAIR AND SENT A WINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THE BELLI.
I I WILL I JUST FROM A
HISTORICAL CONTEXT I I WENT
THROUGH A RATHER LARGE LAWSUIT
[inaudible]
THERE.
TOO ARTICLES THE STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT REQUIRE A TWO
THIRDS VOTER APPROVAL FOR ANY
THAT.
ANY DEBT THAT.
AND THAT INCLUDES I THOUGHT
PENSION LIABILITIES TO THAT IF
YOU CREATED A NEW PENSION THAT
RIGHT AWAY IT HAD TO BE PAID
OVER A LONGER TIME.
THAT SHOULD ALSO --
HAVE A CHRISSY VOTER APPROVAL.
SUPREME COURT DIDN'T WANT TO
HEAR THE CASE BUT I SORT OF GOT
IMMERSED IN THAT SUBJECT SITE I
GUESS.
THE QUESTION THAT I THE COUPLE
QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK IS --
DID.
REMOVING THE ABILITY TO HAVE
VOTERS WEIGH IN ON APPROVING DAT
IS.
IS IS THAT DOES THAT REQUIRE.
A STATE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
WELL WE HAVE SOME BOND EXPOSURE
LIKE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS LIKE
THAT [inaudible]
SURE.
IN A STATEMENT.
A GOOD GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S CONSTANTINE
BURN OFF.
I'M AN ATTORNEY SHAREHOLDER WITH
THE LAW FIRM OF CHRONIC
MOSKOVITZ STEDMAN AND GERARD.
IN SACRAMENTO.
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING MUNICIPAL
FINANCE LOVE FOR APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
WHEN IT COMES? TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO SENATOR --
THAT PROVISION APPLIES TO CITIES
COUNTIES SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
THE I. IF THESE ARE NOT DO NOT
FALL WITHIN THAT CATEGORY SO
THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION.
SO THEN ARE THEY SIMILAR.
TO CERTIFICATES OF PARTICIPATION.
FOR YOU HAVE A REVENUE STREAM
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET VOTER
APPROVAL [inaudible]
YOUR ARM.
IN IN A IN A JUST A VERY
ABBREVIATED WITHIN EIGHT
EXPLANATION YES THEY THEY THEY
COULD BE VIEWED IN THAT MANNER --
CERTIFICATES OF PARTICIPATION
ARE ARE ARE STRUCTURED AS LEASE
OBLIGATIONS AND THERE'S
PROVISIONS IN THEM WHICH OF
PROVIDE FOR EGGS A WAY AROUND
THOSE CONSTITUTIONAL DEBT
LIMITATIONS --
THESE ARE ARE STRUCTURED AS BOND
SO THEY'RE NOT LEASES --
BUT YOU COULD YOU COULD YOU
COULD VIEW IT AND AND THAT WAY.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO EARN A
DESK LAMP ISSUE A LOT OF BONDS
TUESDAY A LOT OF FUN.
BUT JUST TRYING TO GET MY ARMS
AROUND THIS THING I HAVE FOR A
LOOK AT ANTI MAYBE THIS NEEDS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
MR WILL GIVE ANY [inaudible]
OBSERVATIONS --
COMMENTS YEAH SOME ROCK THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I MEAN I
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THE ATTORNEY
HERE IN QUESTIONS THAT --
YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS WE RELISH
THIS YOU KNOW DID REQUIRED HE
THIRDS ABOUT AN AMENDMENT IN THE
CONSTITUTION WE ARE JUST
AMENDING STATUTES THIS IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE ORIGINAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE DISTRICT
PROGRAM WHICH WAS IN STATUTE.
AND YOU GIVE THE DATE OF
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WHEN THIS
WAS ADDED TO THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
I SAID EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
YOU KNOW THAT THE FORMATION --
FOR YOU KNOW LONG TERM DEBT AND
A TWO THIRDS VOTE FOR BONDS DOES
DATE ALL THE WAY BACK TO THAT
PERIOD.
IN FROM HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE I
BELIEVE IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE TRY TO GET
A REAL ROAD IN THE TOWN IT
FAILED BUT THREE OF THE FIVE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS INDICTED
THE CITY AND IT ACTUALLY WENT
BANKRUPT BACK IN THE LATE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SORT OF A
TRIVIA.
QUESTION BUT BEFORE MY TIME
SENATOR YEAH.
IT ACTUALLY WASN'T A AN
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
WAS GERMAN IT WAS A NEW
CONSTITUTION.
BECAUSE WE PASS A NEW
CONSTITUTION TO EXCLUDE TO
CERTAIN ETHNIC GROUPS FROM
CALIFORNIA TOLD HIM IT WAS
PROVED UNCONSTITUTIONAL SO A
PAST SECOND CONSTITUTION.
BUT I THINK THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF THESE
BONDS IS IS DOES IT REQUIRE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT IF IT'S A FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT OF THE VOTERS
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA THAN IT
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE IF YOU'RE
RELYING ON THE DELEGATION THE
PARTICULAR PROJECT WITH ITS
REVENUE BONDS TO VIEW THEY SHARE
THE LIKE.
HE DOESN'T REQUIRE --
THE VOTE YOU SO MUCH SIR.
AND THEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE QUICKLY SISTER
GERMAN ON ONE QUICK QUICK GOOD
ADDITION --
REDEVELOPING BONDS DID NOT
REQUIRE BOTH EITHER.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO WIN FREE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES EXIST
EXISTED BECAUSE THEIR PLATE
BASED ON A TAX INCREMENT.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH NOT ONLY ARE YOU LEARNING
EVERYTHING YOU EVER WANT TO KNOW --
ABOUT -- TAX
INCREMENT DISTRICTS YOU GOT SOME
HISTORY LAYS IN GERMAN AND
YOU'RE GONNA BE GOOD YOUR PARTY
TONIGHT --
SO WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER CENTER
WINNER IN WHAT --
HISTORY FACTOR YOU GONNA DROP
YOUR CENTER WINNER --
I'M AFRAID I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ALL RIGHT.
THERE YOU GO.
AND I'M SORRY --
TRY TO THINK OF SOMETHING RIGHT --
I SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING OUR
MOVING AUTHOR AND CHAIRMAN FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS ON THIS BILL --
IS DOUBLE REFER AND WILL BE
COMING TO THE HOUSE IN COMMITTEE.
IN A FEW WEEKS --
AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE THEIR
COURSE ROOM YOU WORKING ON THE
BILL AND ON POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS
AND ANALYSIS AND SO --
I'LL BE VOTING FOR IT --
TODAY -- BUT
JUST NOT TO READ --
ANYTHING INTO THAT --
BEYOND THE DESIRE TO MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I HAVE SOME VERY QUICK
ITEMS -- BUT
I WANT TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS BEFORE.
WITH EMOTIONAL FOR BISON HERDS
PROVIDE THE SAY LOOK THIS CENTER
BELL -- YOU
HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THIS ISSUE
FOCUS ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
ENDED THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE.
PROJECTS FOR THAT WILL HELP
CITIES BECOME MORE RESILIENT IN
THE YEARS TO COME ESPECIALLY.
DURING THE DOWN TIMES OF WORKING
ON THIS NOW IS ABSOLUTE PORTENT
WEST SACRAMENTO HAS BEEN A MODEL.
NOT FOR THIS ACROSS THE STATE
VERY GRATEFUL --
END ON A TURNED OVER TO YOU SIR
SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY THANK YOU --
FOR A THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND I'M GLAD WE'RE
ABLE TO CLARIFY THE BOND ISSUE --
SENSE --
REDEVELOPMENT WAS LIMITED TO OUR
FISCAL PROBLEMS AT THE STATE.
WE'VE HAD --
DIFFICULT IN.
HELPING IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS IN
CENTRAL TO AVOID --
RECESSIONS IT IT SERVES AS A WAY
OF STOPPING --
THE BAD STUFF FROM HAPPENING
FROM US IN TERMS OF ECONOMICS.
AND WE NEED A PARTNER WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS [inaudible]
TO AND YOU KNOW THESE AGENCIES
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND THIS BUT
WHAT WILL BENEFIT AND HIRE A LOT
OF CALIFORNIANS.
AND GREAT --
MORE HEALTHIER ECONOMY FOR
STATES ORIGIN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND REBOUND
AND LIKE I SAY THESE COMMITTEES --
ONE OF THE BEST AND I KNOW ON
BUYS YOU HAVE --
FORMER SPEAKER HERTZBERG HERE
WHO HAS ALL THE HISTORY AS YET --
CPA MEMBER OF TRULY IT'S THUS
COMES FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
IN.
AC THERE YOU GO.
OKAY SEE THERE YOU GO.
HEY HI DAME.
I JUST HEARD SENATOR BELL COSTS
SO -- IT'S
GOOD STUFF BUT VERY GRATEFUL.
ABOUT MOTION ON THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR FROM SIN HURTS FOR ME
SANCHEZ A RECALL PLEASE.
AND THE MOTION IS A DO PASS --
AS MANY TO THE SINFUL.
REQUIRED BY WIRE I'D MORE LONG.
THEY'LL THEY'LL ODD WORDS WORK
ON THIS REGARD RICARDO.
THE PROBLEM I WILL SEND.
WINNER.
WINNER ON HIM.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA DO A QUICK
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS WE'RE NOT
VOTING THIS.
IS IT OKAY IF WE ARE SHUTTING IT
DOWN OR WOULD YOU LIKE IS TO GET
YOU TO HOLD A ROLE.
YOU CAN SHUT IT DOWN I I WANT TO
DO SOME MORE RESEARCH REALLY I'M
JUST TREES MAYBE IF I GET ASKED
OUT.
SOONER BUT WHY DO WE EVEN BUT
THE 55%.
REQUIREMENT IN THE IN THE FIRST
ITERATION OF THE YOU CAN ANSWER
SURE SO THE I'VE D. STATUE WAS
MODELED AFTER THE I FD LOBSTERS
FROM THE EARLY NINETIES AND THAT
THAT CONTAIN THAT REQUIREMENT.
I'LL I'LL JUST DO A LITTLE
RESEARCH ON THAT THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST --
DOUBLE CHECK THIS --
ONE DISINTERESTED CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THEN THIS
WILL BE OUR LAST ROLL CALL AND
THEN WE'LL SHUT THIS BILL DOWN --
MISS LANCHESTER MORLOCK --
NELSON [inaudible]
WILSON.
NINE RIGHT.
THAT MEASURE PASSES ON A SIX
ZERO VOTE THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTRE BELL.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO SENATE BILL --
FIVE THANK YOU TO OUR WTNESSES.
VERY GRATEFUL.
SINGLE FIVE HIS FOCUS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENT. ONE
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU TO CENTRE
BELL FOR ALL HIS WORK CENTRE
BELL -- IF
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
TODAY IMPRISONING OUR BILL SP --
FIVE BEFORE AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SOME REQUIRE --
WE HAD HEARINGS --
IN THE FALL AND WINTER ALL OVER
YOU KNOW IN LOS ANGELES AND
SACRAMENTO WE HAD STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS.
SO -- THERE
IS A LOT OF IMPORTS --
THAT RESULTED IN THIS BILL.
SO I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR THE
TIME AND EFFORT --
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO STAFF AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN --
THESE AMENDMENTS ALONG WITH THE
AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS NOW IN PRINT.
ADDRESS MOST OF THE IMPORTANT
FISCAL ISSUES RAISED BY OUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS IS
STAGGERING R. SP.
FIVE IT'S A DESPERATELY NEEDED
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS IT HELPS
ALLEVIATE POVERTY CREATES JOBS.
MEETS OUR STATEWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITHOUT
AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA'S HAS FAILED TO
PRODUCE THE ESTIMATE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND NECESSARY
HOUSING UNITS PER YEAR.
THE RESULT.
NEARLY A HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN HAVE
LIVED ON THE STREETS --
THIS LAST YEAR.
ANOTHER TWO POINT TWO MILLION
EXTRA AND VERY --
LOW INCOME RENTER HOUSEHOLDS ARE
COMPETING.
FOR ONLY SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES.
AND I MIGHT ADD.
THE FIRES AND THE DISASTERS HAVE
MADE IT.
EXTREMELY WORST ESPECIALLY AND
SO OF OUR SENATORS DISTRICTS.
SO THIS LEAVES MORE THAN ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
OF OF LOWING LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HOUSING AND AND REALLY OUT AT
SERIOUS RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS.
THE STATE MUSTACHE WITH
EMERGENCY TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE.
THIS BILL SP FIVE MAKES THE
STATE A LONG TERM PARTNER.
AND PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED MONEY
TO SPARE AFFORDABLE SPUR OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
ACROSS THE STATE.
IT PROVIDES A SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING INVESTMENT RAMPING UP TO
TWO BILLION ANNUALLY OVER TIME.
AND OFFERS AN EFFECTIVE FINANCE
TO LOST WHEN THE STATE TO RESIST
DISSOLVED OUR REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
SPECIFICALLY SP FIVE ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO COLLABORATE
ON A STATE APPROVED COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLANS.
WHICH WILL BE FUNDED BY REDUCING
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE AUGMENTATION
FUNDS.
THE FUNDING CAN BE USED IN THE
FOLLOWING FIVE PURPOSES FOR MY
HOUSING.
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
INFILL DEVELOPMENT REVITALIZING
AND RESTORING NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND PLANNING AND ALL RIGHTS
ISSUES.
A MINIMUM OF 50% OF THE MONEY
MUST BE USED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THERE'S A 12% SET
ASIDE FOR RURAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
THE BILL CREATES A COMMITTEE
HOUSE UNDER THE HOUSING COMMUTE
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW
AND APPROVE PROPOSE PLANS
PROVIDING SOME STRONG STATE
OVERSIGHT.
THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO IN POWER
TO TAKE CORRECTIONAL ACTION --
WHEN LOCALS DO NOT MEET THEIR
PLANS OBJECTIVES?
THIS WAS NOT TRUE IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF LAW THAT WE
HAVE WE NOW HAVE A LOG THAT HAS
ACCOUNTABILITY BUILT IN --
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR OUR WITNESSES
AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME.
AND SEA OF YOU'RE THE FIRST ONE
ERROR OKAY.
ASSISTANT MANAGER GOOD MORNING
FLOOR SORCERY A THREE MINUTE
WARNING AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND CENTER BELFRY WORK
ON THIS BILL --
SO ON THIS ONE I'M I'M
REPRESENTING KHALLID AND ALSO
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES --
AS IN IN IN IN SUPPORT.
THIS BILL SP FIVE AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE THERE WERE TWO BIG ISSUES --
THAT THAT ARE PREVENTING THE
WIDESPREAD PROLIFERATION OF TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING ONE WAS THE
ISSUE JUST DRESS THE OTHER.
IS THE LACK OF AVAILABLE FUNDING
FOR MOST CITIES AND COUNTIES YOU
DON'T GET A LARGE SHARE OF THE
PROPERTY TAXES WHY LOT OFONE OF
THESE DISTRICTS HAVEN'T MOVED
FORWARD.
ALSO THAT THE THAT ISSUE WAS
ADDRESSED HEAD ON BY S. B. FIVE
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I THINK IT
DOES SO IN A VERY RESPONSIBLE
AND ACCOUNTABLE WAY THAT PUTS
THE STATE A POSITION MAKING SURE
THE INVESTMENTS --
IN THESE PROJECTS ARE
APPROPRIATE --
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE FINANCIALLY IMPACTED AS THEY
WERE UNDER THE REDEVELOPMENT
PARADIGM.
SO SP FIVE IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT
VERY CREATIVE SHIN TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND SOME OF
THE OBSTRUCTION PROBLEMS THAT
ARE.
PLAGUING THE STATE.
AND SO ON BEHALF OF CALLAN
LEAGUE CITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ARRIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A TEENAGER.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING DAN CAL MUCCI I'M A
RESEARCHER WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL --
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
WE EXAMINE THE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF DIRECT
INVESTMENTS AND ADDITIONAL
LEVERAGE FUNDS FROM SENATE BILL
FIVE AS IT WAS INTRODUCED.
WE USE THE IMPLANT INPUT OUTPUT
MODEL WHICH IS WIDELY ACCEPTED
AS THE INDUSTRY STANDARD FOR
ECONOMIC IMPACT ANALYSIS.
OUR MODEL IS BASED ON OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
AND LIKE THAT PROGRAM WE EXPECT
THE STATE'S DIRECT INVESTMENT
FROMSP FIVE TO BE LEVERAGED
OVER THREE TIMES FROM LOW INCOME
TAX CREDITS.
LOCAL FUNDS OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS
AND PRIVATE SOURCES.
THESE INVESTMENTS COULD
TRANSLATE INTO OVER SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THREE TWENTY TWENTY NINE FURTHER
OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT OVER THE
NEXT DECADE THESE INVESTMENTS
CAN PRODUCE OVER EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW AND REHABILITATED
HOUSING UNITS. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE LOCAL
TAX REVENUE. TWENTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME
AND SUPPORT APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
JOBS INCLUDING ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND FAMILY
SUPPORTING PREVAILING WAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS WITH HEALTH
AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
THANKS TO EXISTING PUBLIC WORKS
APPRENTICESHIP REQUIREMENTS
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE
INVESTMENTS VIA SP FIVE WILL
SUPPORT WORK FORCE TRAINING FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR VETERANS AND
FOR OTHERS JUST BEGINNING THEIR
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS.
APPRENTICESHIP IS BOTH AN
ESCALATOR TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOL
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
HAS A SKILLED CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE WE NEED TO ADDRESS
HOUSING SHORTAGES.
THAT'S ME FIVE WILL NOT ONLY
HELP US MEET THE STATE'S URGENT
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
IT'S A FACTUAL RIPPLE THROUGHOUT
OUR ECONOMY RESULTING IN MORE
JOBS INCREASED CONSUMER SPENDING
AND MORE TAX REVENUE.
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT.
AND THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS ARE PLEASE TO OFFER
OUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND HAVE SOME
FOLLOW QUESTIONS --
GREAT NUMBERS APPRECIATE THAT
LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT IF WE CAN HAVE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR FIRST LAST IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION WELCOME BACK.
CANCEL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WHOSE LETTER OF
SUPPORT AGAIN WAS.
JUST DELIVERED YESTERDAY A SPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITIES OF BURBANK AND
SANDRA FELT STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER JONES.
WELCOME BACK.
MARY ELLEN SHEA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES AND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HEY GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
RAIN A WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT AND CONTINUE TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR ON
MAKING SURE IT'S AS USEFUL TOOL
FOR FOR BEHEADING DEVELOPMENTS
POSSIBLE.
GRATEFUL THANK YOU.
HEY HEY AND CHRISTY FOUR AND A
HALF OF THE CESSATION OF BAY
AREA GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE
A GOOD MORNING MORNING MR TERM
MEMBERS KATIE DONNIE WHO DURAN
WITH THE STATE COUNCIL LABORS
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WEIRD
SUPPORTERS MEASURE I'M SORRY
NUMBER OR OTHER CITIES HAVE
SUBMITTED LETTERS OF OPPOSITION
THAT INCLUDES FATTEN FOUND
VALLEY LOOKING INTO GAIL RUN A
PARK.
MORE PARKS IN CITY LEAGUE PORT
FOR BRAGG LEAGUE WITH MODESTO
SELENA CENTERS IN DANVILLE THANK
YOU AND YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION CORRECT EXAMINATION
YES ARE YOU I'M SO USED TO SEND
UP OPPOSITE ALL THE CRAP.
YES WE ARE ALL IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT CENTER BELLS NOT TO
THROW HIS COPY WHO I CHALLENGE.
HI DAN.
HEY I'M NOT ABOUT EITHER ON
BEHALF OF SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM
LOOK CARDIO AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH A GOOD MORNING
MORNING TERRA BUCKLEY ON WE HAVE
A HOUSE IN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY DID.
DILIGENTLY WITH BOTH YOUR STAFF
AND CENTER STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THIS IS EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I THINK IT'S BECKLEY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK SIR.
GOOD MORNING THE MORNING THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS TIONNE
INSTITUTE A ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THE
EXTRA.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR --
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL GOOD MORNING TIM
CRIMMINS INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN FULL
SUPPORT.
AND WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE PRESIDENT SISTERS AND
CARPENTERS BUT THEY WERE GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SCRIVENS.
THANK YOU LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION LAST CALL
FOR THOSE OR NOT BECAUSE ALL MY
GOSH I'M CERTAINLY GO WITH --
LEAGUE CITY.
HI DATING I APOLOGIZE --
SUPPORT SUPPORT AT ALASKA FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT IT'S
BRING UP THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED OR WHO HAVE CONCERNS AS
WELL WE WELCOME WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COME FORWARD TO TAKE TO GET
THERE.
GOOD MORNING WE WILL TAKE A
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US --
THREAT THESE MANY MONTHS IN
MULTIPLE SIT DOWNS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IF YOU DON'T MIND GIVE
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AN
ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CENTER A JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE VERY MUCH --
SUPPORT THE INTEN OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND C.
T. VERY MUCH SUPPORTS THE WORK
THAT -- BOTH
YOU AND CENTRE BELL HAD BEEN
TRYING TO DO TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
VERY IMPORTANT GOAL WE
ABSOLUTELY DON'T.
OPPOSE PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOW
EARNS ABOUT --
THE IMPACT OF I. SHIFTING ERA
FUNDS COULD HAVE ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS --
WE APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE IT
HAS BEEN CREATED SO FAR IT
CERTAINLY IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT ULTIMATELY IF YOU
ARE LOOKING AT USING THE ROUTE
FUNDS WHILE IT MAY NOT POSE A
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
IF WE GET INTO ANOTHER FISCAL
DECLINE AND WE SEE THE
SUSPENSION OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
WHICH WE NOW HAVE A PRECEDENT OF
HAVING DONE THAT TWICE DURING
THE LAST.
RECESSION DOT COULD PUT IMPACTED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN A MORE
FISCALLY PRECARIOUS SITUATION
FIFTY EIGHT POINT 7% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE ON FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH IT'S OFTEN ARE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE PROVIDING THE MOST
STABLE OPPORTUNITY. FOR STUDENTS
THAT DO YOU --
SUFFER FROM THE EFFECTS OF
POVERTY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
ANOTHER ISSUE SO --
WE ARE TRYING TO WORK TO SEE IF
WE CAN OFFER --
FURTHER STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION --
IF THE BILL DOES CONTINUE TO USE
YOUR ROUTE FUNDS --
IT MIGHT BE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL BUT NEVER THE LESS
WE'RE COMMITTED TO TRY TO WORK
WITH YOU TOWARDS THAT END. FOR
THE IN HEAVY IF YOU WANNA HANG
YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME --
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO HAS CONCERNS OR WHO
MAYBE OPPOSED. TO BE ABLE TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN ON THIS BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE --
I HAVE AWESOME COMMENTS BUT IN
TERMS IN A WINNER IN THE INTO
CENTER HURTS FOR EXAMINER I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN FURTHER
PROOF THAT I SHOULD NEVER MAKE
ANY COMMENTS FROM A COFFEE IN
THE MORNING IN THE COMMENTS I
MADE.
HONESTLY IT'S TWO ONE TWO EIGHT
I MEANT ASIAN AT OTHER BILL I
DON'T THINK IT'S COMING TO THE
HOUSE IN COMMITTEE --
SO AGAIN I'LL BE VOTING FOR THIS
OTHER BUILDS LIKE WHEN THE
HOUSING I DON'T THINK IT WILL GO
STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR YEAH --
NEWS YEAH.
NOW I ONLY I ONLY GOT ONE CENTER
ABOUT -- BUT
I'LL BE VOTING FOR THIS TODAY --
BUT MYSELF AND I WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS IN THIS BILL.
AS IT COMES TO HELPING TO MEET
IN NEXT TWO WEEKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I I RECOGNIZE
THERE'S SOME WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE ON A HOUSING START. TO
WORK WITH THE CHAIR ON THAT
ISSUE ABSOLUTELY NO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO SEND A
WINNER WITH A TURNOVER TO SEND
HER TO BROKEN INTO OUR VICE
CHAIR -- I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BUT I HAVE A
CONCERN NOT ABOUT THE ISSUE BUT
ABOUT THE BIGGER PICTURE THANK.
GOVERNOR BROWN --
FOR HARD TO CHANGE OUR LAW WITH
RESPECT TO REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
IN MY VIEW FOR THREE IMPORTANT
REASONS FIRST.
HE AND HIS ROLE AS THE MAYOR OF
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CITY WAS
INFORMED BY.
ABUSES IN OTHER THINGS THAT HE
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE VELLUM
DEVELOPERS.
TO HE WAS CONCERNED THAT --
USING TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
ADVERSELY AFFECTED EDUCATION
WHICH WE JUST HEARD.
AND COULD DO SO IN THE FUTURE.
AND THIRD THE COUNTIES WERE
BEING ADVERSELY AFFECTED IN THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET FUNDS THAT
WERE AVAILABLE.
SO THE QUESTION BECOMES IN AREAS
WHERE THROUGH AN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT OR THE LIKE HOW DO
YOU GET FUNDING TO GET THERE --
THERE HAS BEEN AND WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEALING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS NOTION
OF OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS USES INSTEAD
OF TAX FUND A PROPERTY TAX MONEY.
WHICH IS SO MUCH STRESS ON IT.
UTILIZES INCOME TAX AND THE
BENEFIT OF THAT IS BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGED THE
LAW THAT MAKES LESS
DEDUCTIBILITY FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS IS THAT IT
THERE'S ACTUAL INCENTIVE IN
CALIFORNIA UTILIZE INCOME TAX.
TO ACHIEVE THE DELIVERABLES YOU
DON'T REALLY CARE WHERE THE
MONEY COMES FROM YOU CARE ABOUT
A DEDICATED REVENUE STREAM THAT
GROWS AS FINANCE WILL THAT WILL
ALLOW THE THE OBJECTIVE TO BE
ACHIEVED WITHOUT ADVERSELY
AFFECTING OTHER IMPORTANT SOCIAL
ISSUES.
AND SO I KNOW THE GOVERNOR JUST
SPOKE RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN
CONFERENCES ALL OVER THE PLACE
IS PEOPLE HUSTLING EVERYWHERE
THE REGULATIONS ARE.
UNDER REVIEW WE'RE WORKING FULL
TIME IN THIS AREA AND SO.
ALL I'M SUGGESTING IS IT IN MY
PURPOSE OF MY COMMENTS IS NOT TO
LOSE ANY OF THE JUST TO SIGN
POST THIS ISSUE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
BOTH WITH RESPECT ON THE TAX
ELEMENT AND TO TRY TO THINK
THROUGH IN RE ENGINEER AS WE GO
FORWARD.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A DEDUCTIBILITY OF
SOMEBODY'S TAXES AT THE AT A
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL LAW THAT
THERE COULD BE SOME INTERESTING
AND EASY WAYS. TO ACHIEVE THE
EXACT DELIVERABLES THAT YOU WANT
TO ACHIEVE THEIR ALTERNATIVE
MECHANISM.
BUT I DO THINK PARTICULARLY
GIVEN YOUR EXPRESSES --
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE CLOSE
THERE TOO BY VIRTUE OF ALL OF
YOUR ROLES IN GOVERNMENT AND
EXPERIENCES EXTRAORDINARY THAT
IS WORTHY.
OF CONTINUING THIS DISCUSSION
BUT I JUST WANT TO SIGN POST IS
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT WE'RE IN
A IN A IS A A PLACE WHERE --
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO TO MAKE A
TURN AND THAT MAYBE GOVERNOR
BROWN WAS RIGHT AND WHAT HE DID
AND MAYBE WE GOT LUCKY WITH
RESPECT TO WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS.
WORKING WITH US AND WE CAN MAYBE
EVEN CLOSE SO WE'VE GOT TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH ALTERNATIVES.
BUT I JUST SHARE THOSE IDEAS
WITH YOU SIR AND I KNOW WHAT A
POLICY WONK YOU ARE.
AND AND IT WANTED TO PUT THAT ON
THE RECORD FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND HAVE THESE KINDS OF
DISCUSSIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND --
YEAH -- WE
HAVE A I WANNA I WANNA --
PUT INTO THE RECORD THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S --
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST --
HAS LOOKED AT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY.
AND IS STATING AND THE LETTER
[inaudible]
THAT -- THE
REQUIREMENTS IN OUR BILL --
MEANS IS EFFECTIVELY WOULD BE
COVERING THE CARS TO THIS
PROGRAM.
AND IN TERMS OF OF SCHOOL
FUNDING.
SO IT AS OPPOSED TO
REDEVELOPMENT REDEVELOPMENT --
JUST GIVE THE ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
IT ENDED UP --
SOMETHING LIKE FIVE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL TAX
INCREMENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
STARTING OFF AT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION NOT FIVE AND A HALF
BILLION.
SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE FACING THIS
IN.
OF IN TERMS OF A PHASE AND
REDEVELOPMENT HAVE FIVE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS --
AND IT IS SET IN A SENSE THAT'S
WHY I SUPPORTED THE THE THE
PROPOSAL OF THE GOVERNOR.
WHEN I VOTED FOR IT?
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST LIKE AN
EITHER OR EITHER WE HAD TO CUT.
FIVE AND HALF BILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF THE SCHOOL'S BUDGET.
OR CONTINUE REDEVELOPMENT WE HAD
WE HAD LIKE --
A CHOICE AND IF YOU REMEMBER.
THE BUDGET SITUATION AT THAT
TIME WHEN I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE --
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE WERE GOING FROM I THINK WHEN
I STARTED WAS A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN BILLION GENERAL FUND
UNDER THE I THINK THE HIGH
EIGHTIES EIGHTY NINE MAYBE.
MILLET BILLION SO IT WAS IT WAS
SUCH A DRAMATIC --
CUT BACK [inaudible]
OF DAD IT RESULTED AND WE HAD TO
REALLY.
MASSIVELY CUT ALL KINDS OF
THINGS OUT OF THE BUDGET
INCLUDING REDEVELOPMENT.
BUT WE TRIED OUR BEST. TO
RESERVE AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
SCHOOLS.
SO THIS BILL.
AS OPPOSED TO REDEVELOPMENT HAS.
A SERIES OF THINGS INCLUDING THE
RE MENTIONING A MEMBERS WE JUST --
THAT.
PROTECT SCHOOL FUNDING.
NOW THE SCHOOL'S ARGUMENT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM ON THIS.
IS THAT YOU'RE STILL MAKING.
THE GENERAL FUND POT LOWER.
THAT ARGUMENT WOULD STILL APPLY --
FOR OPPORTUNITY CELLS AS WELL IT
WOULD IT WOULD IT WOULD.
YOU KNOW THEIR THEIR ARGUMENT OF
THE GENERAL FUND BEING --
LESS RESOURCES PUTS MORE
PRESSURE ON SCHOOL FINANCE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE ARGUMENT
BUT THE BILLITSELF THAT
ARGUMENT COULD BE APPLIED TO ANY
ALLOCATION.
OF GENERAL FUND MONEY THAT'S
OUTSIDE THE SCHOOLS HOW ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW I JUST YOU KNOW BRING
UP ONE WAS A DIME ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WAS CENTER MORE LOG
ON THAT ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS YOU KNOW.
WHEN YOU'RE ONE UP A BILLION
BILLION DOLLARS JUST IN ONE YEAR?
AND AND AND THAT YOU SAID YOU
DON'T THINK THAT PUT PRESSURE ON
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM OF COURSE TO
DO IT -- SO
THIS BILL IS A FACE UP THE OTHER
THING THAT HOUSE IN THE BILL IS
WE HAVE A WE HAVE WHAT I WHAT I
CALL I I TYPICALLY CALL PANIC
BUTTON.
IT ALLOWS A LEGISLATURE TO
FREEZE AND A WHOLE.
THE TAX INCREMENT PROGRAM.
SO THE LEGISLATURE AS OPPOSED TO
REDEVELOPMENT WOULD JUST KIND OF
CONTINUES.
WITHOUT OUR CONTROL THIS ALLOWS
US.
TO FREEZING CONTROL THAT POINT
IN TIME WHERE THE FISCAL
PROBLEMS.
ARE A SUCH THAT THAT --
IT GOES INTO THE RESERVES OF THE
STATE WE ALLOWS US THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THAT --
THE THIRD THINK THE THIRD THING
IT DOES IN TERMS OF CHANGES FOR
REDEVELOPMENT.
REDEVELOPMENT --
REALLY WAS FURTHER MORE IT
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THIS BILL HAS A LOT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IT
SPECIFIES WHERE THE MONEY HAS TO
BE SPENT IT REQUIRES THEM TO
COME UP WITH A A PLAN TO SUBMIT.
THAT OUTLINES WHERE THE MONEY'S
GOING TO BE SPENT.
IT ALLOWS A COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
THAT IT ALLOWS A COMMITTEE TO
SAY IF YOU ARE COMPLETING YOUR
PLAN YOUR HOUSING PROJECTS --
YOU KNOW.
IF YOU'RE NOT COMPLAINERS
HOUSING PROJECTS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU PUT IN THE PLANT.
IT ALLOWS THE COMMITTEE --
TO TAKE TAKE ACTION.
SO THERE ARE THERE ARE --
THOSE KINDS OF CONTROLS THAT
READ ABOUT WHAT REALLY THEN HOW
READ ABOUT WAS ONE OF YOU KNOW I
CHAIRED THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
IN SAN JOSE SO I I I I THERE WAS
NO CONTROLS ARE SIMPLY REPORT
WENT TO THE STATE COMPTROLLER
EVERY YEAR AND THAT WAS PRETTY
MUCH IT.
SO.
SO -- THIS
HAS USES DIFFERENT.
AND BY SETTING UP THE PARAMETERS
OF WHERE WE WE WANT TO SPEND THE
MONEY -- WE
ARE BENEFITING CERTAIN THINGS
AND TARGETING THE MONEY TO
CERTAIN THINGS THAT'S WHY.
THE MAJORITY THE MONEY WILL BE
SPENT ON HOUSE.
BECAUSE WE NEED WE HAVE A CRISIS
WE HAVE TO SPEND MONEY ON THAT
WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING.
SO HOW DO YOU DO THAT WITHOUT
HURTING THE SCHOOLS THIS IS THIS
IS THE THE THE WAY WE'RE TRYING
TO FORMULATE THIS BILL AND
THAT'S WE CAME UP WITH THIS BILL
AFTER A LOT OF DISCUSSION WE
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED IT WITH THE
SCHOOLS WERE STILL GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO TO WORK WITH THEM --
CENTER HERTZBERG AND AND THEY DO
NEED MORE MONEY WE GOT IT WE GOT
TO GET MORE MONEY TO SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE ALSO SO --
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO KEEP.
SCHOOL KIDS HOUSE.
I HAVE SCHOOL KIDS IN MY
DISTRICT WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT
CAME TO ME.
AND SAID HE WANTED TO BE ALLOWED
TO PUT --
CARS IN THE PARKING LOT AT THE
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE
THE FUNKY SO THE PARENTS ARE
HOMELESS CAN CAN.
HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO PARK AND
THE BILL ON THAT AND LIVE YOU
KNOW SO WE WE GOT WE GOT KIND OF
THIS --
SITUATION WHERE --
YEAH THAT DOES AFFECT THE
SCHOOLS IN THE EDUCATION OF KIDS
DOESN'T IT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A
HOME.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE I I WAS
HOMELESS AT THE ONE TIME WHEN
OUR HOUSE CAUGHT ON FIRE AND
BURN DOWN.
SO I'M I'M AWARE OF WHAT IT
MEANS YOUR WHAT IT WHAT.
TRAUMA --
GOES THROUGH THE FAMILY ONE
TWELVE OF US TO HAVE A PLACE TO
LIVE.
SO SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
OF WHICH YOU CAN USE IT HURTS
FOR KLEE SLOANE OF THOUGHT JUST
FOR THE SPIRIT OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE RESPECT FOR THE OPERA
ONE OF THE AUTHORS HERE.
THE PRESENTER IS A GUY I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND I SAW HOW
YOU HAVE PUT ON THE VERY EVE
THOUGHT THROUGH OVER THE
EXPERIENCE.
THAT THE THE PROCESS SEES WHILE
I WAS TRYING TO DO.
IT WAS TO RAISE THIS ISSUE IN
THE SENSE THAT.
ON YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT YOU WANT
HER TO TIER THREE ISSUES I DIE.
THE IDEA IS A NINETY EIGHT THE
THE IDEA IS TO FIGURE OUT IN THE
SCHEME OF THINGS THERE'S NEW
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
THAT CAN REDUCE THAT COMPRESSION.
THAT ALSO MAYBE OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS TOGETHER IN OTHER
METHODOLOGIES COULD BE A MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY THAT FACT CREATE
MORE HOUSING --
WHICH THE GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT
THE OTHER DAY IN IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT --
SO SO THE THE THE A A AND AND A
LARGER DYNAMIC OF PEAK SHAPING
THE JUST THE LAST POINT I WANT
TO RAISE IS THAT THE WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT.
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT THAT YOU
SUFFERED THROUGH WHEN YOU WERE
HERE AND I WASN'T AT THAT TIME --
WAS WAS THE THE VOLATILITY OF
THE OF THE REVENUE SYSTEM THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD A
3% DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY AT
23% DOWNTURN IN THE BUDGET.
THAT COMES FROM THE MECHANISMS
THAT WE USE TO FIND THE STATE
AND THE CHALLENGE THAT HAS.
THE GENIUS OF THE OPPORTUNITY
ZONE ELEMENT AS IT INTEGRATES
WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT AND ALL
OF THE OTHER ELEMENTS AS I WANT
TO JUST.
AGAIN I'M NOT DIGGING AS DEEP AS
YOU HAVE A JUST ONE TOP WANTED
FOR THE DISCUSSION THIS
COMMITTEE IS ITS PEAK SHAPE.
BECAUSE IN ESSENCE WHAT IT DOES
IT DEALS WITH CAPITAL GAINS THAT
WE DON'T DEAL WITH SO WE CAN
CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE SE SERVICE
TAX THAT WOULD GO LIKE THIS.
GET RID OF THE PEKING.
USE THIS TO HELP COMMUNITIES
THAT OPPORTUNITY ZONES THIS
COULD ALL BE PART OF A LARGER
DISCUSSION FINALLY TOUCH THIS
BECAUSE IT'S IN THE WORLD THAT
I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH IN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION TO THIS
COMMITTEE MY FORMER CAPACITY.
OF WHICH YOU'VE BEEN WITH US FOR
OVER FOUR YEARS WHEN I WAS HERE
ORIGINALLY AND JUST TO THROW ON
THE TABLE FOR THINKING BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
STUFF I THINK THIS IS ALL ABOUT
VOTING FOR THE MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAD A IS ONLY PART OF THE
SOLUTION FOR YA.
I THINK CENTER WINNERS TAKEN --
CHARGE OF GETTING THAT --
WORKING ON THAT THIS IS THIS IS
A PIECE OF IT THOUGH.
THIS THIS IS SO ALL RIGHT AN
OPPORTUNITY ROSE COULD BE
ANOTHER PIECE WE NEED A LOT OF
IT WE GOT WE'RE WE'RE SUCH AND
SUCH BAD TROUBLE WE NEED TO DO A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS. TO TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM PROBLEM.
THANK YOU IT IS AN INTERNAL
COMBUSTION INDOCIN WINNER I
THINK THE ONE ISSUE.
WHEN CENTER BELL AND I WERE
LOOKING AT THE ISSUE OF
OPPORTUNITIES --
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS IN
NUMBER ONE LOOK AT WERE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN SEVEN PLACE IT
BENEFITS THE WEALTHIEST WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEN THERE IS A HUGE HIT TO
THE STATE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE
IT CAPS GAINS TO THE STATE
GENERAL FUND --
TO TWENTY FORTY SEVEN AND
THERE'SNO WAY TO BE A CONTROL
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE TO
CONFORM WITH NEW TAX CODE WITH
THE FEDS.
SO THERE'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
HIT -- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ZONES NOW THAT FEDERAL TAX
CONFORM HAVE MOVED FORWARD.
THERE ARE NO SAFEGUARDS FOR
DISPLACEMENT WITHIN --
THE OPPORTUNITY ZONES IN NO
LOCAL CONTROL TOTALLY UP TO THE
INVESTOR WHO IS ADVANCING ON AN
OPPORTUNITY SO INTO THEIR SOME
CONCERNS ON THAT.
WHICH WHICH WE'VE BEEN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WELL THE
CHALLENGE OF THE TAX PIECES WE
HAVE TO CONFORM THOUGH AND IN
WE'RE TALKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THERE IS A BIG HIT THREE TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN BUT THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT THEY'RE VERY WELL AWARE OF
IT AS WELL AS FAR AS THAT FLOW
IN BECAUSE IT DOES CAP GAINS.
ANYTHING GOING FORWARD THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN BUT I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE DISCUSSION
BUREAU --
WERE KIND THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CENTER THIS CURRENT BASED
HERE IN CENTER WINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IN TWENTY TWELVE WHEN RDAS
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE WERE.
REMOVED I WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD.
OF SUPERVISORS FOR COUNTIES I'D
DO IT.
DEALING WITH THE SUCCESSOR
AGENCIES AND ALL THE REST BUT I
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH SOONER BELL
THAT'S GONE ON SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE AND THEN YOU'RE PART OF
IT.
I SEE AT LEAST A HALF DOZEN
INITIATIVES TO KIND OF BRING
BACK REDEVELOPMENT SOME FORM OR
FASHION --
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS THE E. R..
I. F. THESE WOULD YOU CREATED
WITH A SENATE BILL.
SIX TO EIGHT WE'VE GOT THE
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT AUTHORITY WHICH WAS
CREATED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
THAT'S TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NEIGHBORHOOD IN PHIL FINANCE IN
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENT ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE SEAPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS. TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
REVITALIZATION FINANCING
DISTRICT FOR FORMER MILITARY
BASES.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN SO YOU GOT SO
MANY EFFORTS GOING ON IN AND NOW
YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER.
ONE I WAS KIND OF COULD YOU TELL
ME HOW THEY ALL.
IN A RELATED.
WELL MAYBE I COULD TALK YES THE
PARK OR WHO'S.
TRY TO PULL THE STUFF TOGETHER --
TO RESPOND.
I THINK THE THE RESPONSE I'D
GIVE TO THAT IS THAT ALL OF THE
ITEMS YOU JUST MENTIONED ARE
FORMS OF TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
BUT BUT ALL OF THEM SHARE THE
COMMON CONSTRAINT THAT.
THE FUNDING THAT CAN GO TO THEM.
IS PURELY VOLUNTARY AND MAIN
MAINLY BASED ON ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT --
SHARE AND THAT'S THAT'S WHEN THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH THESE
NEW TOOLS.
IS THAT THE THE SHARE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE.
JUST ISN'T ENOUGH TO MAKE A GO
OF A MEANINGFUL --
WHAT IS REQUIRED TO ACTUALLY
ISSUE BONDS AND FINANCE PROJECTS
SO?
THAT'S THE UNIQUENESS OF THIS
BILL IT PROVIDES A MECHANISM TO
INCREASE THE PULL OF FUNDING
THAT WE GO TO THE TAX INCREMENT
STREAM --
PUTS THE STATE AND IN CONTROL OF
IT -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S RESPONSIBLE
SO IT DEALS WITH SORT SORT OF
THAT THAT MAIN ISSUE THAT ALL OF
THOSE MECHANISMS YOU MENTION
SHARE.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE BILL --
IN THROUGH THE YOU KNOW ALL THE
MATERIAL.
IT SEEMS EXTREMELY COMPLEX AND
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DID A LOT OF
WORK AND MAYBE TRY TO ANSWER TOO
MANY QUESTIONS ARE PERTINENT.
SO MUCH BUT I I WAS CURIOUS WHY
IS IT SUCH A SO MASSIVE.
THE BILL IS NOT HOUSES IT'S TWO
HUNDRED THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE
IS THERE IS A A BUILD UP OVER
TEN YEARS.
FROM TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
COMPARED TO FIVE POINT FOUR
BILLION AND REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS.
WHEN IT WHEN THE THE LAST YEAR
REDEVELOPMENT?
SO IT BUILDS UP. TO A CAB IN THE
BILL OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS TEN
YEARS FROM NOW BUT I AM I REALLY
SO IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT A YOU PUT INTO THIS
BILL THERE'S THERE'S SO MUCH
RICHER YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT IT JUST SEEMS SO.
COMPLEX I UNDERSTAND HOW YOUR
PHASING IT THE OUT OF ON OKAY I
CAN GIVE YOU AN ANSWER IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT IS SAID TO
CENTER HERTZBERG.
WE ARE VERY AWARE I AM
PERSONALLY VERY AWARE.
OF ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT
REDEVELOPMENT --
HAD.
WITH THERE'S A LOT OF STUDIES ON
THIS.
OUR REDEVELOPMENT WAS NOT GOOD
IN TERMS OF RETURN ON ITS
INVESTMENT I MEAN THERE'S A LOT
OF MISTAKES IT WAS.
MONEY THAT SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT
COULD HAVE BEEN USED IN A BETTER
WAY MAYBE.
PERHAPS IN TERMS OF AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO DEFINE OUR
SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE --
YES AS OPPOSED TO WHAT WE USED
IT FOR WITH REDEVELOPMENT.
THE HOUSING REQUIREMENT WAS ONLY
20% IT DID REQUIRE THEM TO SPEND
THE MONEY IT REQUIRED THEM TO
SET ASIDE THE MONEY.
IN A LOT OF CITIES DID SET ASIDE
THE MONEY BUT THEY NEVER SPENT.
YOU KNOW THEY KEPT THOSE BOUNCES
VERY HIGH.
AND OUT OF THIS BILL DEALS WITH
THE VERY THE REASON WHY.
THIS BILL SOUNDS COMPLICATED IT
REALLY ISN'T BUT IT DEALS WITH
THE PROBLEMS THAT WORK WITH THAT
WE WERE RECOGNIZED AND WITH
LESSONS WE LEARNED.
AND BAD REDEVELOPMENT FINANCING
OF THE PAST.
AND THAT'S WHAT I ANSWER TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG HAS YET TRIED
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING --
SO IT CREATES A ANSWER TO THE
PROBLEMS.
AT AN EVENT IF YOU REALIZE IT'S
WE CAN'T JUST HAVE A SIMPLE BILL
THAT ALLOWS REDEVELOPMENT.
I DON'T I WOULD VOTE FOR IT
MYSELF I THINK THAT WE THAT
OCCURRED IN THE PAST I LIVE SO I
HAD TO I HAD TO DO IT A
DIFFERENT WAY.
AND AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
IT NO A NEW WAY IN ORDER TO
REFLECT HARD WORK AND SO I'M
SORT OF POKING AND ASK YOU A
LITTLE BIT CAN'T WE CAN'T GO
BACK TO WHERE IT WAS.
BUT STATE OVERSIGHT I'M GETTING
A LITTLE CYNICAL ABOUT STATE
OVERSIGHT.
WE WILL GET.
STATE AUDITOR REPORTS AND
NOTHING HAPPENS WE HAVE ELLIE --
REPORTS NOTHING HAPPENS NOW THE
ONLY OVERSIGHT I'M SEEING ON
HOUSING IS I HAVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SUING ONE OF MY CITIES.
YEAH SO ARE THAT THAT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE A A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT WITH THE PARENT COMPANY
AND ITS SUBSIDIARIES --
COULD YOU HAD.
TELL ME IN THROUGH THIS WHOLE
PROCESS WHAT YOU ENVISION AS
STATE OVERSIGHT NOW IT'LL BE
EFFECTIVE OTHER SOME VERY STRICT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IN THE
BILL.
IT HAS OTHER OVERSIGHT HAS AN
APPROVAL PROCESS FIRST OF ALL
THEY CAN'T DO IT UNLESS THE
SUBMIT IT AND GET IT APPROVED
THERE HAS TO BE A PLAN.
THEY HAVE TO BE SPECIFIC IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE PROPOSING
IT HAS TO BE FOR THE FIVE
PURPOSES WHICH ARE IDENTIFIED IN
THE BILL.
IT HAS TO HAVE FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROGRAM%
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IF IT DOESN'T
RELATE TO THE FIVE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE.
IN TERMS OF THE BILL IT WON'T
GET APPROVED I'LL HAVE TO GO
BACK AND RE WRITE IT.
AND THEN ONCE IT'S APPROVE
THERE'S AN ANNUAL REVIEW THERE'S
AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED NOT ONLY TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT TO US.
THE LEGISLATURE THERE HAS TO BE --
A REVIEW OF THEIR PROGRESS
READING THE THE PURPOSES OF OF
THE PLAN THAT THEY SUBMITTED --
AND ALL THAT STUFF IS REVIEWED
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND I THINK
IT IT PROVIDES.
A VERY GOOD SET OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES --
FILLABLE FISCAL AND FROM A
PROGRAM STANDPOINT.
MISTER CITY MANAGER YOU'RE READY
TO PUT UP WITH ALL THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST THINKING THAT THAT
THE IT REMINDS ME OF A MORE LIKE
A GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS
ANGELA ANNUALLY --
I THINK SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE MAKE --
THE NEW PROGRAMS WORK --
THIS WOULD.
BE A GAME CHANGER POTENTIALLY SO.
I THINK I'M READY TO RESTORE IT.
ONE WAY THE MONEY EXPRESSES
RUSHER SIN WHEN.
WITH ADDITIONAL COMMENTS I HAVE
A FEW -- BUT
ONCE IF WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
CENTRE BELL --
I WANT TO ECHO WHAT YOU HAD SAID
THIS BILL HAS BEEN BASED IN
EVIDENCE AND TESTIMONY FROM.
OUR REPRESENTATIVES BIG CITIES
AND SMALL.
RURAL COUNTIES AND URBAN.
I AND ALL WALKS OF LIFE BUSINESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES.
AND I THINK THAT --
REASON WHY WE'RE SEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT THIS IS
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
WILL WORK FOR THEM.
AND WHAT WE HEARD --
INCENTER MORLOCK WAS AT THIS
SAME HEARING THE SAME JOINT
HEARING LOSS ANGELES THAT THERE
IS A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP.
FROM THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT IN A RICE --
ADDRESS CORRELATION IN A RISING
STATE.
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ABSOLUTE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE OF
THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
AFFORDABLE HOMES IS SEEN BETWEEN?
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND THE MODERATE.
LOW IN VERY LOW CATEGORIES WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
BUILT WITHOUT AN ONGOING REVENUE
SOURCE FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES
[inaudible]
I ONE OF THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCES
WHEN IT COMES TO OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS IN THIS BILL IS AT OR
MANDATING THAT 50% 50%.
OF ALL FINDING HAS TO GO TOWARDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM WHAT WE
SAW.
IN PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF WHAT
FOLKS CALLED REDEVELOPMENT SO WE
GOT TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS IN THIS CRISIS.
THE REASON WHY WE ADVANCE STATE
OVERSIGHT IS BECAUSE LET'S BE
HONEST ARE THERE WERE A FEW NOT
VERY MANY BUT THERE ARE A FEW
BAD ACTORS.
WHO GAME THE REDEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM AND WE WANT TO BE A LEARN
FROM THOSE PREVIOUS MISTAKES?
THAT IS WHY WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DIRECT STATE OVERSIGHT.
OVER THESE FUNDS AND WHICH
PROJECTS ARE GONNA BE APPROVED
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY NOT
APPROVED --
AND IT'S ABOUT PUTTING
SAFEGUARDS IN TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE JOB DONE ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND THERE ARE STRATEGIC OFF
FRANCE WAS IN THAT BILL SO WHEN
WE DO HIT A SIGNIFICANT
RECESSION.
IN A FISCAL EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED --
THAT FINDING SO THAT WE'RE NOT --
IMPACTING --
PUBLIC EDUCATION BY THE WAY
THAT'S THE LAST THING I THINK
ANY OF US WANT TO DO AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT I'M ANY MORE SPECIAL
THAN ANYONE ELSE BUT MY WIFE IS
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL --
WENT TO PUBLIC SCHOOL MY LIFE
FROM A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER --
AND MY GRANDFATHER WHO IS
PASSING ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL WOULD WHACK ME UPSIDE
THE HEAD --
AND AS WE SAW THERE IS AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS BY LET'S
SAY LANDLESS OFFICE THAT WITH
THE REGULATIONS THAT ARE PUT
INTO THE BILL NOW --
THERE WILL NOT BE AGE --
IMPACT TO PUBLIC EDUCATION
SCHOOL FUNDING BECAUSE OF THESE
OFFERINGS THAT HAVE --
BEEN IN PLACE.
THROUGH THE VARIOUS ITERATIONS
OF THIS BILL --
OF ALL IN IT WITH THIS IS THAT --
THIS THERE IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT.
IN OUR PHILOSOPHY HAS BEEN THE
ENTIRE TIME IT'S NOT DO THIS
FAST LET'S DO IT RIGHT.
IS A WE HAVE BROUGHT IN FOLKS
WHO OPPOSE REGARDING FOLKS WHO
AGREE TO TRY TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS RIGHT.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS -- IN
THERE ARE A SINNER WINNER IS
BEING A CHAMPION ON THIS INNER
BALANCE BEEN A CHAMPION AND THIS
IS BEING ABLE TO GET HOUSING
BUILT FASTER AND TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE FUNDING. TO GET
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILT.
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CENTRE BELL
FOR HE'S --
BEING A CHAMPION ON THIS ISSUE
TO MY LEFT --
PETERSON WHO IS JUST --
I'VE BEEN ON ALL TECHNICAL
DETAIL -- IN
AT TIMES BUT OPINION IS I
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
WORK THAT WENT INTO THIS AND I
JUST DID NOT WANT --
TO MOVE AWAY.
FROM JONATHAN YOU WANT TO SAY
ALSO THANK YOU SUNSHINE WHO'S
HERE FROM CENTER BELLS OFFICE.
WHO KNOWS HOW TO CUSS AND GET
THE JOB DONE SO --
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
BATTLE --
FOR ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- IT
IS SIX THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS.
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND GOOD PAYING JOBS.
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
LABOR INCOME. SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AND IMPORTANTLY TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A POSITIVE
NET IMPACT.
IT WILL HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON LEVY IN OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE
STATE ECONOMY.
IT'LL HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
ELIMINATING POVERTY.
IT WILL HELP AREAS THAT HAVE A
LARGE.
POVERTY IN THEIR AREA.
AND IT WILL HELP LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
NET IN INTERNATIONAL TAX
REVENUES IF OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS.
SO WE'LL HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE TAX BASE OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTRE BELL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTERS FOR THE MOTION IS DO
PASSES AMENDED DAY WHAT CENTER
WINNERS HOUSING COMMITTEE --
MISS LANE CHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
HI WHERE I'M MORE ALONG.
BELL.
SO I HOPE TO WORK.
WHICH WERE GUY HOTEL ROOM.
HELLO HI NELSON.
YES THE NO WAY --
WITH -- I
FIVE ONE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR A GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE NICE
WORK TO SENATOR ABOUT.
WE NOW --
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
ITEM ON THE DOCKET IN THAT
SENATE BILL.
TWO OH FIVE CENTER HERTZ BURGERS
READY GO FOCUSING ON BUSINESS
LICENSES AND IT'S CONTINUED WORK.
ON ALL ISSUES IS STORM WATER
DISCHARGE.
ALL ISSUES STORM WATER DISTRICT
BACK THE RIGHT.
BUT TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING ON AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH. TO THIS
ISSUE MISTER SENATOR WE'RE GONNA
GIVE IT ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS
THAT FOLKS --
EXIT THE CHAMBERS AND THEN WE'LL
KICK IT BACK UP AGAIN.
IF SOMEBODY ELSE DOES YEAH.
TRAFFIC IN THE BACK ROOM --
YOU.
GREAT GREAT GREAT
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
MISTER SENATOR WOULD YOU MIND IF
WE OPEN THE ROLE ON TWO ITEMS WE
MAY HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL AS IF WE
CAN JUST A GIVE US ONE MINUTE
PLEASE.
WE'LL START WITH THE RULES RULES
WE HAVE A PHOTO OF SIXTY FOUR
DOLLARS [inaudible]
DURATION [inaudible]
MOST.
WELL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T CHANGE
IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE US A TWO
MINUTES REAL QUICK.
THANK YOU.
SO WE CAN [inaudible]
RECONSIDERATION SEPARATE MOVIE.
AND THE BILL COMES.
FORTY THE MOVIE IS SET
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THE
SEVEN I'M SO HAPPY.
ALONG WITH LOTS OF PRODUCTS. TO
DO IT AGAIN [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
I WE ARE GONNA TAKE THREE ITEMS
OF BUSINESS --
PRIOR TO TURNING IT OVER TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THE FIRST IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECONSIDERATION VOTE.
ON SP.
FIVE WHICH WOULD THEN CLEARED
THE BOAT.
AND ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE ON SP FIVE ONCE
AGAIN.
THEN WE'RE GONNA DO A QUICK ADD
ON ON TWO ITEMS OUR COMMITTEE
RULES AS WELL AS SP.
THIRTY FOUR SO IT'LL BE A TOTAL
OF FOUR VOTES. TWO ON SP.
FIVE IS THERE A MOTION TO
RECONSIDER THE COMMITTEE VOTE.
ON SP.
FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
NIELSEN.
ON THE VOTE. FOR RECONSIDERATION
MISALIGNED JESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE CHOIR HI WHERE I WORE A
LOT [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
WELL I I HELLO.
HELLO I WILL SOON.
I WAITER. FIVE FIVE ZERO THE
RECONSIDERATION VOTE PASSES.
WE WOULD NOW LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE A VOTE ONCE AGAIN ON SP
FIVE IS THERE A NEW MOTION TO
MOVE SP.
FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND THIS IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
MISS LANE CHESTER ROLL CALL ON
SP FIVE WIRE HI WHERE I'M MORE
LOCKED.
THEY'LL.
THEY'LL I HURTS BIRD HI THIS
BOOK I HER TITLE.
THE TITLE I NIELSEN.
YES AND I WINNER.
YOU HAVE A KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AS
CENTER WINNER WILL BE RETURNING
TO COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO DO
TOO QUICK ADD ON BOATS THE FIRST
IS GOING TO BE ON OUR COMMITTEE
RULES.
THE CURRENT VOTE.
AT CURRENT RULES IN OUR
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO KEEP MISLED
INTERESTS AROUND SHE IS AMAZING --
AND CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
MISS LANE CHESTER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS RICARDO
[inaudible]
I SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GONNA CLOSE
THAT BOW DOWN MISS LANE CHESTER
WELCOME BACK --
IN SHE'S BREAKING OUT THE
MARGARITA IN OUR COFFEE CUP NOW --
THERE YOU GO SHE SAID I ONLY
WISH SHOW RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
S. B. THIRTY FOUR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO MISS LANE
CHESTER.
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE WIRE HI
WIRE HI [inaudible]
HELLO. SEVEN ZERO VOTE SB THIRTY
FOUR IS CLOSE THAT BILL IS
MOVING.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
OVER TO S. B. TWO OH FIVE CENTER
HERTZ BERGEN WANTS A THANK YOU
CENTER HER ALONG WITH YOUR
WITNESS IS UP FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I START WITH THE ACCEPTING BOTH
OF THEM POSED AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
BOMB.
AS YOU CORRECTLY NOTED THIS IS
YET ANOTHER HERTZBERG STORM
WATER BILL.
AT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT WE'VE GOVERNMENT WHERE IT'S
SO I CALLED THE RIGHT HAND LEFT
HAND ISSUE.
WHEN YOU'RE SOMEBODY WHO'S?
IN CALIFORNIA YOUR SUBJECT IT
WILL BE A LIVE TEST CITY LAWS TO
COUNTY LAWS TO STATE LAWS THE
FEDERAL LAWS.
AND OFTEN WE THE LEFT HAND IS NO
THE RIGHT HANDS DOING.
AND WE'RE CREATING ALL SORTS OF
PROBLEMS AND STORMS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COMES
ALONG AND SAYS OKAY WE'RE
PASSING UNDER THE FEDERAL CLEAN
WATER ACT.
THIS REQUIREMENT OF THE NATIONAL
POLLUTION DISCHARGE ELIMINATIONS
OUR SYSTEM PERMIT WHICH NPDES
PERMIT.
BASICALLY SAYS YOU GOT STORM
WATER IN ESSENCE IT RUNS OFF IT
IT PUTS JUNKIN THE OCEAN AND
YOU GOT TO GET A PERMIT IF
YOU'RE.
IF YOU'RE ONE OF THESE ENTITIES
THAT HAVE A BUSINESS THAT GETS
QUALIFIED IN THE SITUATION --
THAT THE DOES THAT THEN YOU HAVE
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
THAT IT IS REQUIREMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL LAW AND
WHAT DOES IT DO.
IT THEN COMES UP WITH THESE
GENERAL PERMIT FOR STORM WATER
DISCHARGE AND IT'S CALLED AN
INDUSTRIAL GENERAL PERMIT IGP
CARPET ON TOP OF PERMANENT TOP A
PERMIT.
WITH THE STAGE JUST SIMPLY
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING THAT
ACROSS THE BOARD EVERYBODY
AGREES WITH.
AND THEN IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WE'VE BEEN FACING IN THE
LEGISLATURE UNBELIEVABLE ANGST.
BECAUSE UNDER THE STATE WATER
PERMIT SYSTEM WHERE STUFFED RUNS
OFF THE STREETS OR RUNS OUT OF
BUSINESS AND STUFF CITIES CAN
NOW BE HELD LIABLE IN THEIR
SUBJECT AND COUNTIES LIABLE.
BECAUSE THEY COULD BE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT FINES.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES WHAT I
REALLY LIKE ABOUT EACH PRETTY
SIMPLE IT SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE
ONE OF THESE COMPANIES AND ONLY
ABOUT. 20% IT APPEARS THAT ARISE
THAT REQUIRES NEEDS ONE OF THESE
PERMITS WHEN YOU APPLY FOR A
BUSINESS LICENSE OR RENEWAL OF
THE BUSINESS LICENSE WE'VE NOW
GIVEN. NINETY THREE MONTHS THE
REPRIEVE ON THAT.
YOU BASICALLY GOT ON THE FORM
PUT IN YOUR NUMBERS FOR YOUR
PERMITS AND WE'VE ASKED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YOU JUST TWO THINGS
ONE EXCEPT A DOCUMENT THE SIDES
OF THE NAME OF THE LIKE OF THE
BUSINESS UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY AND TO GO TO THE WEBSITE
WHICH WE NOW REQUIRE.
AND LOOK FOR THE CODE AND FIND
IF THEY QUALIFY.
THE EFFECT OF THAT IF YOU JUST
DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT THE
BUSINESSES BUT THINK ABOUT THE
CITY OR THE COUNTY NOW YES THEY
ARGUE THERE'S A COUPLE COUNTIES
DON'T HAVE PERMITS.
OKAY WE'RE SOLVING 98% OF THE
PROBLEMS AND YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF THE SITUATION IN MOST CITIES
DO AND ALL THESE PERMITS ARE
REQUIRED IN CITIES.
BUT THE REALITY IS WITH A COUPLE
MORE LINES YOU KNOW INTEGRATED
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
SITUATIONS.
AND YOU KNOW JOKE AROUND WITH MY
STAFF AND IF THE BUT YOU KNOW IF
THERE COULD BE AN ARGUMENT WELL
JUST A SHOULDN'T HAVE IT BE A
BURDEN TO A CITY OR COUNTY.
TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT A FEDERAL
LAW ONE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAID EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA HAD TO WEAR BLUE
SHIRTS IT MIGHT NOT BE RELEVANT.
BUT THIS IS A LAW THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY DIRECTLY RELEVANT TO
LIABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THEY'RE HAVING A BIG HEART
ATTACK OVER SO IT SEEMS TO ME
YOU KNOW YOU ALWAYS GET THE
ARGUMENTS.
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE'VE ALL
BEEN INVOLVED WITH FOR A LONG
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
IT'S A NEW COST ALL WHAT'S NEW
BURDEN BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH
TO ME.
THE BENEFIT OF THIS THING AND
THE REASON IT MAKES SENSE LAWS.
AT THE FRONT END OF A PERMIT
AGAIN NOT A FOUR COUNTIES THEY
DON'T HAVE PERMIT REQUIREMENTS
FOR BUSINESS LICENSES.
BUT BUT MOST WITH EVERYBODY ELSE
WE HAVE AND SECONDLY WE'VE WE'VE
BASICALLY DEALT WITH A MUCH
LARGER PROBLEM THAT ALSO AFFECTS
THE LIABILITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES A
RICKY DID ESSENCE REQUIRES THOSE
THINGS IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE IN IN
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY PRETTY
EFFECTIVE I THINK IN TRYING TO
THINK THROUGH GOVERNMENT IN A
WAY THAT INTEGRATES THESE VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICIES AT
EVERY LEVEL.
AND I WOULD WRECK I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AS X.
THINGS RICK CELEBRATING AT THE
RATE THEY ARE.
AND WE IN GOVERNMENT ARE NOT AS
EXHILARATING AS QUICKLY IS TO
TRY TO CREATE THE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE THE BUSINESSES
WHATEVER.
EASIER WE SEE ALL THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY DOING THAT THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE.
SOMEBODY MIGHT NOT NEED NO THEY
NEED THE PERMIT RIGHT AND THEN
THE GAULS AND SOMEBODY COMES
AFTER IN LOS ANGELES IS ONLY.
FIVE INVESTIGATORS FOR WHAT.
SIXTY THOUSAND SIX THOUSAND
PERMITS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
EITHER I HAVE IN MY NOTES BUT
WITH WINDOWS.
ANY EVENT.
THE POINT IS THAT IT MAKES IT
EVEN EASIER IN MY JUDGMENT IS
MUCH AS WE CAN INTEGRATE THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND PARTICULARLY
ONE LIKE THIS.
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT AND AS SUCH
IMPACT ON ALL THE PARTIES
INVOLVED WITH THAT.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WE'VE
GOT TWO VERY BRILLIANT WITH THIS
IS HERE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COAST KEEPERS AND ALSO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE. FOR THE
METALS COALITION BECAUSE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SUPPORT LETTERS HERE YOU'VE GOT
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO REALLY
RESPONSIBLE THE AUTO DISMANTLE
THERE'S METAL PEOPLE AND STUFF
THAT ARE COMPLYING.
AND THEN YOU HAVE A WHOLE HOST
OF THEIR COMPETITORS WHO ARE
COMPLYING SHOULD WE NOT AS A
GOVERNMENT REWARD PEOPLE AND LET
THEM YOU KNOW BECAUSE THESE
CHALLENGES WHERE YOU'VE GOT A
WHOLE HOST OF RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE
WHO WERE DOING THE JOB.
AND HELPING PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT I DON'T WANT TO
START WITH.
YEAH MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS SINNERS PARK POLICE FORCE
GEORGE YOUR MINUTES SIR --
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OMITTING SOME OF ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEP RELIANCE
ON ONLY TWO POINTS AND AND ONE
CLARIFYING POINT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK FROM THE
OUTSET.
THIS BILL IS NOT REQUIRING
CITIES OR COUNTIES.
TO CONFIRM THAT PARTIES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PERMIT THE
PERMIT REQUIRES BEING WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS DOING BMPS
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
REQUIRING IT IS ONLY REQUIRING
THE CITIES OR COUNTIES TO ENSURE
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT NEED TO
ENROLL UNDER THE PERMIT OR AND
ROLLING UNDER THE PERMIT THAT IS
THE ONLY OBLIGATION WITH THIS
BILL --
SECOND I JUST WANT TO ILLUSTRATE
WHY THIS BILL IS IS IS REALLY
SOME POINTS AND SO HURT DID A
GREAT JOB --
SO WHEN A RIVER BECOMES OUR
WATER WAY BECOMES TOO POLLUTED --
THE REGIONAL BOARDS SET WHAT'S
CALLED A TOTAL DAILY MAXIMUM
LOAD A TMDL WITH THEM THE
REGIONAL BOARD WILL DO IS ASSESS
WHAT IS THE LIMIT OF THE AMOUNT
OF LET'S JUST SAY METALS.
WE CAN PUT IN THE RIVER --
WITHOUT IMPAIRING IT AND SO WE
COME UP WITH THAT LOAD LIMIT AND
THEY FIGURE OUT EVERYONE IN THE
WATERSHED THAT IS WORSE THAT IS
DISCHARGING INTO THAT RIVER SO
LET'S TAKE A LATE --
THEY'VE A METALS TEAM DEAL.
SO THEY SETTLE A LOAD TARGET AND
THEN THEY FIGURE OUT EVERYONE
THIS THIS CHARGING IN THERE AND
ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE LIABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING THAT
TARGET.
BUT IT'S UNDER HURTS BERG SAID
ONLY ONE OUT OF FIVE PEOPLE --
FACILITIES ARE UNDER THE PERMIT
TWENTY BILLY AND ARE PAYING
THOUSANDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THE MUNICIPALITIES ARE --
TO COMPLY WITH THIS PERMIT WHICH
JUST CREATES AN INEQUITABLE
SITUATION BUT ALSO WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET THE WATER WAYS TO
MEET THAT LOW TARGET IF 80% OF
THE IN INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE UNDER THE THE
PERMIT.
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE UNDER THE PERMIT
OR DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED --
TO PUT IN THESE BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES TO MEET THESE LOW
TARGETS AND SO WE REALLY FEEL
LIKE THIS IS US A SIMPLE
SOLUTION BUT AN ELEGANT WAY TO
GET FOLKS TO COME UNDER THE
PERMIT --
YOU KNOW ONLY TWENTY ONE OUT OF
FIVE FOLKS --
THAT THAT'S A BIG CONTRAST AND
WE NEED TO GET FOLKS ENROLLED IN
THIS AND SO FOR THAT I ANSWER.
THANK.
WHAT IS STILL HERE?
THANK YOU SENATOR IN COMMITTEE
LAURIE KAMMERER TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
METALS COALITION --
THE C. M. C. --
IS HOME TO ABOUT --
FOUR THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE
METAL --
INDUSTRY AND THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL.
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY --
THE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS INVOLVED
IN -- THE
METAL -- THE
INDUSTRY AND THE NON FILER ISSUE
IS AN ISSUE IT IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE -- THE
SMALL BUSINESSES MOST OF THESE
METAL COMPANIES ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES FAMILY OWNED.
AND RUN AND THEY HAVE TO COMPETE
AGAINST THOSE COMPANIES WHO ARE
NOT FILING WHEN THEY HAVE
COMPLIED WITH THE LAW --
SECONDLY THE WHEN THE RUN OFF
GOES FROM A NON FILER TO A FILER.
THE FILER IS LIABLE AND THE
FILER IS THEN LIABLE FOR ANY
PENALTIES OR ANYTHING THAT THAT
COMES AT AS A RESULT OF THE RUN
ON AND THE THIRD POINT I WAS
GOING TO RAISE IS THAT THE COST
OF THE PERMIT --
ISN'T AS AN ADDED COST TO THE
BUSINESS AND IT PUTS THE FILER --
AT A COMPETITIVE.
DISADVANTAGE AS I MENTIONED SO
FOR THOSE REASONS THE CALIFORNIA
METALS COALITION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE SPELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAD TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS OR THE
EXCUSE ME COMMENTS SIR
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
MISSION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ONLY GOOD FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDPOINT IN TERMS OF IMPORTANT
WORK WE NEED TO DO THERE BUT
ALSO LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR THE GOOD ACTORS THAT ARE
COMPLYING WITH THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE PERMITS HAVE A PLAN.
AND WE'RE IN COMPETITION WITH
FOLKS THAT DON'T AND IN SOME
INSTANCES A SENATOR POINTED OUT
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THEY
NEED TO HAVE A PERMIT.
A STORM WATER PERMITS THE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WHICH IS
REALLY SMART IT WILL CATCH THOSE
FOLKS AND HELP BRING THEM INTO
COMPLIANCE AND LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR THE GOOD ACTORS.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH AS MAKE YOU
PAY FOR YOUR HERE THANK YOU THAT
COULD OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT FOR SOME CLASSES WAS
ORGANIZATION GOVERNMENT PLAN
AGAIN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE WEST
COAST CHAPTER FOR THE INSTITUTE.
RECYCLING INDUSTRIES IN SPORT
IT'S BEEN FUN AGAIN.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING THREE
SEPARATE EVENTS ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
MORNING.
MORNING NANCY SHOWED SOME HAVE A
FEEL OF A STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE.
PLEASE IF YOU ARE IF YOU DON'T I
CAN AFFORD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
THE MORNING.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES WE DO HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION ON THE BILL
WERE SORT OF A TWEENER ON THIS --
ONE AND WE DO REALLY APPRECIATE --
THE INTENT OF THE MEASURE A
CENTER HERTZ BIRD OUTLINED A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FACE WE'RE TRYING TO
COMPLY WITH OUR OWN MUNICIPAL
STORM WATER PERMITS.
REALLY APPRECIATE HIS WORK ON S.
B. TWO THIRTY ONE AND ALL THE
OTHER ATTENTION HE'S GIVEN THIS
ISSUE AS IT IS A HUGE CHALLENGE.
CHALLENGE FOR US --
THE BILL AS DRAFTED DOES PRESENT
A COUPLE IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES FOR COUNTIES IN
PARTICULAR THAT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE --
FIRST AS WAS MENTIONED THERE ARE
NO QUITE A FEW THERE'S ABOUT
SIXTEEN SO A THIRD OF THE STATE
IN THE UNINCORPORATED AREA
DOESN'T HAVE.
A CURRENT BUSINESS LICENSE SO
THEY WOULDN'T FALL.
UNDER THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL IN ADDITION THERE ARE
NUMBER OF OTHER COUNTIES THAT WE
ONLY REQUIRE A BUSINESS LICENSE
FOR CERTAIN ACTIVITIES --
THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY AUTHORITY
OVER INCLUDING INCLUDING --
CARD ROOMS OR OR THE PARTY SCENE
AND BUYING OF FIREARMS FOR
EXAMPLE --
SO A NUMBER OF BUSINESSES THAT
MIGHT NOT FALL UNDER THE
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT.
I AND THEN FINALLY THERE ARE
ALSO A NUMBER OF COUNTIES --
THAT HAVE AID MUNICIPAL --
EXCUSE ME A MINISTERIAL PROCESS
TO ISSUE A BUSINESS LICENSE AND
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY AN OVER THE
COUNTER PROCESS AS YOU ALL KNOW
BUT COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IT REQUIRES THE BUSINESS TO FILL
OUT AN APPLICATION.
SUBMIT A FEE --
AND PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
PAPERWORK AND THAT COUNTY THEN --
ISSUES THE PERMIT SO THAT WE DO --
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING TO STAFF A
AND YOUR YOUR COMMITTEE FOLKS
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THEIR
EFFORTS --
WE DO THINK THAT THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IT WOULD
CHANGE THAT MINISTERIAL PROCESS
AND IT REQUIRES TO ROUTE THAT
PERMIT TO AN APPROPRIATE STAFF
PERSON THAT COULD THEN.
VERIFY -- WE
WOULD THIS DEMONSTRATING
COMPLIANCE BY SHOWING THAT --
THEY'RE APPROPRIATE PAPERWORK
DEMONSTRATING THAT THEY HAVE
THAT PERMANENT --
IN PLACE SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
THAT MEANT MINISTERIAL PROCESS
IN PLACE AND NOT REALLY GOES AND
SPEAKS TO SORT OF THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE WITHIN A JURISDICTION.
THIS STATE --
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT
MIGHT NOT BE THE ONLY STATE
PERMIT THESE BUSINESSES NAME WE
DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
IMPRESSION THAT THIS IS THE ONLY
THING.
THE ONE STOP SHOP FOR A BUSINESS
LICENSE BECAUSE THEY MIGHT ALSO
NEED ADITIONAL PERMANENCE --
FROM.
OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTION
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL DEPENDING
ON THE BUSINESS SO IT'S JUST A
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT
FOR US AND DOESN'T QUITE CAPTURE --
FROM A STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE AS
IS MENTIONED IN THE BILL IT'S OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN OBVIOUSLY --
BUT IT REALLY ONLY AFFECTS A
SUBSET OF BUSINESSES IN A SUBSET
OF COUNTIES FROM FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE --
BUT AGAIN APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
STAFF AND OF COURSE THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHOR AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
GRANDFATHER WERE RECEIVED SECOND
HAVE YOU HOLD IF YOU DON'T MIND
IT'S RIGHT THERE LET'S SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IS IN A
POSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME.
LAST CALL ON OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
OF ACTIVATED HAS SENT HURTS FOR
BETTER DRESSES --
ANY ISSUES AND THEN WE'LL OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND HURTS.
FOR YEAH ON PAGE THREE OF THE
MEASURE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
PAGE ON THIRTY SEVEN IS IS ON
APPLYING TO A COUNTY. FOR
INITIAL BUSINESS LICENSE WELL IF
THERE IS IF THEY HAD ALL
DIFFERENT IBEATS BY OPERATIONAL
LAW IT SEEMS TO ME IF THERE'S NO
LICENSE THERE BE NO REQUIREMENT
BUT IF IF YOU NEED ALSO
SUSPENDERS CLARIFY THAT.
THAT'S A REASONABLE SOLUTION --
IF IT'S NEEDED I I DON'T REALLY
THINK SO BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE IT IF YOU SAY I WOULD NEED
TO APPLY.
FOR A LICENSE IN MY COMMUNITY
FOR MINOR --
SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENED IN
YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BUT THAT'S
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THIS THIS
ISSUE WOW WHEN YOU TRY TO CHANGE
THINGS.
IF THE ARGUMENT IS WELL YOU KNOW
YOU YOU'VE GOT ONE COME
COMPLIANCE FOR A COUNTY DOES IT
MEAN THAT THAT INCLUDES
EVERYTHING ELSE WELL WHERE DO
YOU START.
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE TO THEN GIVE
LEGAL ADVICE YOU CAN JUST SIMPLY
HAVE A DISCLAIMER YOUR FORM OF
THIS IS ONE THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GUARANTEE YOU COUNTY
COUNCIL WAS A CITY ATTORNEYS
WILL REQUIRE THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST GOOD LAWYERING OF WHAT
YOU'D OTHERWISE SAY BUT IS THAT
AN ARGUMENT. TO SAY WELL YOU
DON'T TAKE A FIRST STEP TO MAKE
THINGS BETTER THE POINT THAT WAS
MADE THIS IS BEING AN ELEGANT
SOLUTION WHERE IT HAS.
BOTH IMPLICATION FOR OTHER
PEOPLE ARE COMPLYING WITH THEIR
SHARING THE OBLIGATION AND ALSO
FOR THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE THE OBLIGATION SO.
YOU KNOW I'VE CLEARLY WE'RE OPEN
TO FIX ANY MEANINGFUL OR WILLING --
TO TO WORK WITH ANY WAS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE SO APPRECIATED%
WE TOOK THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE ASKED IN THE THREE
MONTHS AND THE CLARIFICATION YOU
ASK FOR WHICH I THINK WE'RE
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SINNERS BERGEN
YES THE THE THE WAY THE
COMMITTEE READS IT ARE THOSE
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT HAVE A
BUSINESS LICENSE THIS WILL NOT
THERE WILL NOT BE TRIGGER SO
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AS IN HERDS BERG ON THAT I AM
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CLARIFICATION WOULD LIKE ME TO
SEE IF ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE ENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MR JR.
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE SACK LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP.
WE WE HAD A COASTAL COUNTIES
COCKE IS DO YOU STILL HAVE IT.
WOULD IT WOULD JUST APPLY TO
THOSE COUNTIES.
NO IT UP IN THE AIR ALL FIFTY
EIGHT HAS A BUSINESS LICENSE
OKAY OKAY SO THEN I'M NARROWING
IT DOWN TO SPECIFIC COUNTIES
DOESN'T.
PROVIDE THE SOLUTION WHO CENTERS
REQUIRE WE FEELING COMPELLED TO
HELP OUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IN THIS REGARD OTHER THAN.
WE GOT SOME BUSINESSES THAT ARE.
COMPLYING OTHERS THAT ARE YOU
WERE TRYING TO AVOID NOT HELPING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORK WHO
IS IS IF THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS
HAVE BEEN.
ADOPTED AND ENFORCED BY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD REGIONAL
BY THE STATE AND THEN TO THE
NINE REGIONS.
OF THE REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD AND SO OUR
COMMUNITIES WE GET FIND BOTH AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL ON NPDES PERMITS.
THROUGH A HELPING ABOUT WE'RE
HELPING OUT THE THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE GETTING FINED.
WE'RE HELPING OUT THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE THAT ARE GETTING FINED
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE POLLUTION
ARE DOING IT.
WE'RE HELPING OUT MUNICIPALITIES
AND COUNTIES WHO OTHERWISE GET
FINED BECAUSE OF THE THE THE
CONTRIBUTION THESE POLLUTANTS
AND TORE A WATER STREAMS WITH
NOT JUST OCEAN BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
RIVERS AND THE LIKE.
AND IT WILL HELP OUT THE HEALTH
OF THE OF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
WHO HAVE TO DRINK WATER THAT
GETS POLLUTED FROM THIS THIS RUN
OFF.
SO I WOULDN'T SUGGEST THAT WE'RE
JUST DOING THIS FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S REALLY FOR THE
FOLKS HERE BUSINESS FOLKS AND
PEOPLE IN QUALITY OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THRESHERS CENTERVILLE --
IN TERMS OF FINES AND THAT WHOLE
PROCESS TO ENFORCE THE FEDERAL
LAW -- DONE
INVOLVES A LOT OF ATTORNEYS COST
OVERHEAD.
AND AND WITH THIS REDUCE THAT OR
MAKE IT LESS LIKELY.
THAT THAT KIND OF PROCESS --
WOULD EXIST.
THEREFORE THEREFORE MEANING THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ATTORNEYS ANYMORE.
IS THAT IS THAT --
I CAN I JUST TAKE THAT
PERSONALLY AT ABOUT A READ THAT
I JUST WANT.
IF YOU WERE TO REDUCE THE
GOVERNMENTAL COSTS.
TO WOULD YOU --
COMMENT ON THAT WELL TAKE THE
FIRST PART ON BUDGETARY NEEDS
BUT I DO THINK IT REDUCED
GOVERNMENTAL COSTS DOWN BOTH IN
TERMS OF FINES AND AT AND THE
LIKE AND THAT'S H. A BROADER
COMPLIANCE BY ALL PARTIES TO THE
SYSTEM WORKS.
THIS SITE WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL SAN JOSE IT WAS LIKE.
ALL THE TIME AND LITIGATION --
YOU KNOW JUST CONSTANT ON GOING
KIND OF SITUATIONS [inaudible]
AND IS THERE ANY CONTROL IS IT
WHEN YOU DO A FINE IS THERE ANY
SPECIFICATION.
OF WHERE THAT FINE MONEY GOES.
WHERE IS THAT MONEY GO I MEAN
WHEN THERE'S YET IT DEPENDS ON
THE LEVEL OF OF THE PENALTY IN
THE FINE --
IT IN MANY CASES --
THEY'RE CALLED SUPPLEMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS WHERE
WHERE THEY GO BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO HELP --
LEAVE WHATEVER --
THE POLLUTION WAS BEING CAUSED --
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST AN IN
ADMINISTRATIVE FINE --
THE STATE WATER BOARD JUST
ASSESS THAT AND PUT THT BACK
INTO THEIR THEIR STORE WATER%
PROGRAM USUALLY INTO THEIR
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM SO I I I
FIND -- THE
SYSTEM WHERE EVERYTHING IS DONE
THROUGH FINDS IS.
IS A BAD THING IN GOVERNMENT AS
A GOVERNMENTAL RULE I MEAN.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT'S WARRIOR TOWARDS JUST.
MAKING PEOPLE DO THINGS BY FINE
SETS.
JEREMY YOU WANT YOU WANT
REGULATIONS THAT.
ENFORCE REGULATIONS BUT THROUGH
LICENSING PROCESS IS BETTER.
IS IS IT WOULD YOU IS THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL EXACTLY IT
JUST TO TRY TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
WORK AND BECOME SELF.
EXECUTORY SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE ALL THE SYSTEMS GOOD
GOVERNMENT ARE THINGS THAT YOU
CAN WORK ON AUTOMATIC PILOT LIKE
THIS THAT HAVE A GOOD EASY.
CONSUMER INTERFACE WHEN PEOPLE
ARE WORK IT AREN'T FRUSTRATING
AND THAT SOLVE PROBLEMS WAY IN
ADVANCE SO YEAH EXACTLY RIGHT I
THINK IT'S LIKE I DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT IT IN THOSE TERMS CENTER
BUT I THINK THAT'S A VERY
INSIGHTFUL CRISIS THINK ABOUT IT
THAT WAY.
YOU KNOW AND AND YOU KNOW LIKE
WHEN WE FIRST WE GOT FINED FOR
VARIOUS THINGS ON WATER ISSUES.
THERE WAS NO CONTROL WHERE THE
MONEY WENT I WENT TO A A FINE
BOOK AND THEN THE FINE BOOK IT
WAS USED BY.
SOME ENTITY FOR WHATEVER.
ON REGULATED PURPOSE THEY WANTED
TO USE THE MONEY.
FOR THAT'S BAD GOVERNMENT I
THINK I THINK THAT'S MONEY
WASTED OR NOT WASTED BUT YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE SPENDING THE MONEY
THERE'S NO RULES PLAYERS.
YOU KNOW --
AND I THINK THAT'S THE MONEY
SHOULD BE USED TO CLEAN THE
WATER. FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO WHEN DONE
AS PURPLE SO THEY DON'T LOSE THE
FIRST PLACES WERE CATCHING HIM
IN SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
IN THE FIRST PLACE WERE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE BUT THAT'S
GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEARCH FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.%
AS RELIABLE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE I THINK THE THE
NOTION IS ELEGANT SOLUTION AND I
LIKE THE THIS KIND OF THINKING --
IT'S A GOOD WAY --
TO TO TO OPERATE GOVERNMENT
BETTER THAN FINDS BETTER THAN
PUTTING THE BURDEN ON THE COMPLY
OUR AND CERTAINLY --
IS IN THE INTEREST OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
IS THERE A MOTION --
TO APPROVE SENATE BILL.
TWO OH FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTRE BELL THIS IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
MISSING CHESTER RECALL PLEASE
REQUIRED BY WIRE I WORE A LOT.
MORE WALK I'D THEY'LL.
THEY'LL LIVE.
BIRTH HI.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
R. I. DAISY GERMAN IT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND
THAT IS A BIPARTISAN LIKE FITS
BUMPED BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO THE
REPUBLIC'S ANYMORE.
ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH --
WE ARE GOING TO ADD SINNERS SO.
SOME HOUSEKEEPING QUICKLY WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE --
PAIN -- FOR
CENTER WINNER ON TV ON TWO BILLS
SENATE BILL FIVE SP.
TWO OH FIVE SOON WE WILL BE BACK
IN A PROXIMATE LEE LEVIN.
FORTY FIVE OR NOON.
SO -- WE ARE
IN COMMUNICATION WITH HIM NOW --
BUT LET'S OPEN UP THE ROLE ON S.
B. TWO OH FIVE FOR SENATOR
HURTADO --
AND MISS LANE CHESTER. TWO FIFTY
FOUR TO TO LOOKING WORK.
WITH THE COURT.
IT IS [inaudible]
FIVE ZERO FIVE OUR GERMAN.
LET'S OPEN UP AN SP TWO OH FIVE
TEN OR TOTAL CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO CHAIR VOTING I'D
MISSING JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SIX ZERO WHAT GOVERNS HOW DO I
LIKE IT --
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN --
IN WAIT FOR SENATOR WINNER.
DELAYS IN GERMAN.
OUR NEXT COMMITTEE HEARING IS
SERIOUS [inaudible] ONE ON A
GIVE US ONE MOMENT
THEY DO HAVE
AN ID --
BOTH.
SIR TITLE CENTER BELLS GOOD TO
GO -- AS
WELL AS CENTER NIELSEN SO --
WE ARE ALL CUT UP QUICK MISSING
CHESTER ON BOATS WE ARE GOING TO
BE -- CENTER
WE IS NOW GOING TO BE BACK AT
NOON.
SO -- WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
TEMPORARY RECESS THE COMMITTEE --
COME BACK AT NOON TO BE ABLE TO
ADD CENTER WINNER ON SP FIVE IN
SP.
TWO OH FIVE SO WE'RE GONNA
TEMPORARY RECESS --
UNTIL APPROXIMATELY NOON FOR
WILL ADD CENTER WINNER ON AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR EVERYONE'S
WORK TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WELCOME
BACK WE ARE NOW GOING INTO THE
LATE EDITION OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WE TWO BILLS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE --
ADDING ON TO SENATE BILL FIVE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FIVE ONE FORTY
NINE MISSING JUST A RECALL
PLEASE [inaudible]
WE WINNER HI [inaudible] SIX HE
IS YEAH I THINK THAT'S WHERE ALL
THE PLEASE IN GERMAN THAT I'M
GONNA MAKE A CORRECTION --
WITH SENATOR OR WINNERS VOTE IT
IS A SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE RULE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
FOLLOWING UP ON AN ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP TWO OH FIVE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO CZERNY NINE MISSING
CHESTER WEINER.
WINNER ON SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT OR CLOSE IN THE ROLE
WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT WEDNESDAY
FOR OUR SECOND BILL HEARING AT
NINE THIRTY THANK YOU THE
SERGEANTS IN TO THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE STAFF TALK TO NEXT
WEEK